two hello hello
it's Wednesday September 28th let me
just get this intro and before the off
the rail starts guys today's episode
sponsored by Harry's I know it's coming
uh thanks for joining us everybody we
actually we didn't have one ready for
today you guys didn't prepare one you're
effing with me
that's gotta be something here is Ethan
Klein
[Music]
are you really good oh my God
get your balls off my baby
whoa
[Music]
it could be the pepper and everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
fine
and fine
[Music]
you're not that guy
there's more than a dip
oh [ __ ] spooky haunted mansion
what's happening in there
oh no sexual no not him
sexual fantasy no not Tucker unimportant
Palace has an
has enough wow disrespectful
disrespectful guys
okay you know I thought exploding milk
exploding milk exploding milk do not
waste that sweet milk milk milk milk
milk milk milk milk milk milk milk milk
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh man you guys are off you guys are
truly off the rails wow wow what a
journey that that was last last week was
like a DMT trip this week's was more
like a Peyote trip either way definitely
had an ego death again yep Ian and Zach
the collab of a lifetime he's a great
guy wow when you bring those two brains
together the darker brain meets the um
hurricane Gallery beautiful brain
hurricane Ian is what we call him the
hurricane yeah yo Ian you really messing
stuff up in Florida right now
I wonder I was gonna say welcome
everybody and a special hello to Florida
which is half submerged under the ocean
Ian is set to really [ __ ] things up
right now uh yeah yeah thanks a lot but
uh of course another great intro by The
Dream Team back there thank you guys
we haven't talked about the exploding
milk meme yet that's tomorrow
isn't it did we not mention well it was
in the dock last week but I don't know
if we yeah we ever got to it exploding
Milk porn maybe we'll after [ __ ] did a
segment on exploding milk hentai porn
uh it was great so
but anyway guys welcome actually before
we get started
we have a fantastic show uh for a change
for you guys
I know it's usually a nightmare but this
one's good I promise
we have first of all uh the try guy
Scandal what's the title was that it was
that the try guys try infidelity
which people in the chat seem to really
enjoy so right well well that's an apt
title certainly it's just a one man do
they ever do videos where it's just one
guy
well now they might
let me see that's so good this story
like I don't care about the try guys at
all
but this story is just so funny man and
obviously if that guy's life is in ruin
and uh but you know what sometimes
that's just totally fine
I mean I feel bad for his wife obviously
I'm fine people and kids off yeah oh
[ __ ] he got kids oh damn well anyway I
don't get too deep into that because
we're gonna talk about that later but it
is good oh everyone's spamming tickets
you guys didn't forget
um we're also having a this is super
interesting we're getting a call in
later from Matt Turner who got third
place on the current season of Big
Brother who's a big old fupa Trooper
Stan the girl who won
the whole thing was actually a big
hassanabi head
so I don't know you know if you were a
serious uh Cooper Trooper you would have
won the damn thing for me but okay third
place is fine
um that's gonna be interesting and then
uh the chess cheating scandal I'm
actually really looking forward to
talking about that
and I'm cheating this episode
cheaters and then later uh me and a b
will be taking to a pool of Vaseline to
wrestle in a speedo thong sweet I didn't
know about that but let's let's do it
surprise I got it all set up back there
nice it'll be nice it'll be a fun time
nice I wrestled the bear so basically
guys okay um for members we're doing a
48 hour window
where members can buy uh tickets to the
first live show in four years this is a
big event for us it's going to be a lot
of fun you can enter the code wait don't
at they're going to be spamming at an
end Discord what okay I thought you were
about to say it
in Discord where our members are and
also if you're a member on the community
tab we're gonna make a post there okay
so I'm gonna I'm posting the link to the
ticket page right now in the chat yeah
and you guys are gonna love the password
too and yes like he just said I'm going
to publish a community post to members
only right now
all right
there's uh only about 700 tickets so
you know they're probably gonna go
pretty fast I'm assuming or maybe nobody
cares and I'm dead wrong but that is
possible too
all right
Discord you can see the password on the
members tab of our I think I'll actually
be in the community tab but it's it the
post is set to only members will be able
to see it yes okay let's go
put your hands in the air yes and I'm
gonna drop it say SRI live in the
December 20th at 7 pm
in L.A Hollywood okay let's go put your
hands in the air five we're doing it
live
we'll do it live yeah so that's up there
for you guys
um looking forward to seeing y'all there
it's gonna be a lot of fun it's gonna be
so much fun my goodness oh my goodness
also
um I want to say again guys I see people
are panicking because they're not in
Discord go to the um
go to the community tab it it'll be
there if you're a member you'll see it
on our YouTube Community tab on our
YouTube channel in fact you should even
get a notification of it usually those
Community posts when they're set to
members uh push
thank you CAD cat caddy cat for the
gifted
if I get to tubs thank you
thank everybody
and then I guess we should say like well
I guess you said this is just a window
um it will open up to everybody on
Friday assuming it's not sold out which
I guess it could but
there are still tickets available by
Friday Friday they will open up to the
general public there it is gonna be so
much fun
and like I said if
if this sells out like before the show
ends I'll know that like
maybe we can do a bigger venue next time
so more people can come
oops I mean we didn't want to bite off
more than we could chew it's been a long
time since we've done one of these well
I don't want to humiliate myself and
then like only sell half the seeds right
my ego is fragile enough as it is you
think I'm gonna be able to recover from
that
uh people saying front row sold out
already
um
all right well anyway moving on so
that's there we'll update you guys uh
the other thing I want to do is thank
you to all of our members you know I
posted our very first ever members
podcast
yeah on yesterday and uh the comments
were great I'm super happy it was super
fun people are saying it's sold out that
can't be true
I think uh probably just the front row
two tickets are sold out
wait
wait I mean it's possible I don't know a
lot of people here wait hold on hold on
hold on
but let me go try and buy a ticket yeah
we have 25 000 fans here right now about
how many of them are going to be able to
be in La you know what I mean right
I almost came to La for your first show
and I lived in Michigan that's because
you're the yeah not everyone's got your
dedication I appreciate that though
thank you yeah I appreciate that a lot
I think people are saying it's sold out
what the [ __ ] that's crazy if so it's
all sold out are you kidding me Jesus
wow that's a lot faster than I
anticipated well I'm logging in right
now
very nice uh well thank you guys that's
exciting I think we'll need a bigger
venue next time cheers Louise I need a
bigger boat yeah we're gonna need a
bigger boat
yeah and hopefully guys please don't
bring a gun and shoot me or any of the
cast I'm just saying that because like
you know people I mean you know people
are crazy and you killing me is not
you're not gonna be able to absorb my
soul or anything I'm just speaking to
the people who are like in a psychosis
State and think that I'm you know
reading their thoughts I'm just telling
you that's not true please don't bring a
gun if you kill me I will not you know I
need a machine gun
you're not going to be reincarnated in
my skin or anything like that I just
want to let you debunk all those
those thoughts now
okay
it's a little dark but you know it's on
my mind
you know what I mean well I'm glad who's
gonna take Ebola for me like let's be
real not me let me just say you're lucky
I didn't come to that first show
well who's taking a pull-up for me I'm
taking a bullet for you obviously
yeah
go ahead speak the truth would you be
pissed if you took a ball for me no
that's fine it's fine yeah that's fine
and he died we've had this conversation
a few times she's okay
all right there you go AB stay close
I got you
and uh I do see some people in the chat
uh saying
um will we be able to watch the stream
yes to be clear this will still be put
out as a normal episode so even if
you've got tickets you'll be able to
enjoy the experience but limited amount
of seats that's why no one does it like
us this whole thing is going to be alive
wow for everybody to enjoy no pay wall
by the way unbelievable none of that yes
it's all free for our beautiful fans wow
it's sold out okay that's fun
I I'm still skeptical but I just went
and yeah I mean it's it's saying join
waiting list I guess let me uh email our
people and see if it really sold out
that fast I just asked them Dan I think
oh you asked okay next show will be at
the Greek
Auditorium Stadium
crypto.com Arena yeah the Greek isn't
actually that big I mean it's bigger
than the thing we're doing 5000 suits
isn't it seating
yeah maybe it's around I want to do yeah
around 6 000 actually I want to do a
pretty bad with Fouseytube at the Greek
and Drake will be there oh [ __ ] maybe I
should just bill It featuring Drake just
to [ __ ] it just because it's awesome
oh right is that the Greek oh I forgot
about that we should do it at the Greek
featuring Drake
why not
Drake and fousey oh I'm sorry guys I
thought that it would be easier to buy I
can't I'm I'm really shocked that it
already sold out okay next next time
we'll do a bigger Stadium I'm sorry guys
but like I said it's gonna be live
everyone's gonna be able to enjoy it
what'd you say FouseyTUBE
I felt worthless no
before that yeah I felt gay I felt that
note of that like that's just based on
what they told me I don't know why that
[ __ ] gets me every [ __ ] time the
follow-up to I felt game
foreign
[Applause]
just to make sure there isn't some like
weird glitch or something but I mean I
guess it's certainly Within
within reason that it sold out that
quickly a lot of people well I just want
to say thank you guys that is really
awesome and you guys are the greatest
that ever did it so somebody just
donated ten dollars they've got front
row tickets coming from New York and
it's the day before my birthday let's go
Mary so excited wow you guys are
sweethearts coming in from New York wow
yeah I do Wonder though because like the
first show in a while obviously has way
more demand any of people coming from
out of state
we do it every month I promise you every
month will be sold out that really yes
see that was my rationale going into
this and and talking with the promoters
is when we were discussing the size we
were like well if we want this to be an
ongoing thing it's like yeah this first
one and we could do it at a two thousand
three thousand person uh venue and
that'll easily sell out the first time
but the third time the fourth time maybe
we should just creep up a little bit
right so I guess we'll see let's find
out where the real demand is because by
the way it caused a shitload of money
when you get these places
it costs so much money and when you step
up like if you don't sell like at least
80 of the tickets you're like taking a
loss it's pretty wild
we should just do an ace Fest type thing
in the summertime yeah you you fan of
Lancaster you like that City we had fun
we had a good time we had a good time
hey and uh for anybody that wasn't able
to secure tickets I'm sorry but you can
make it up by checking out Zach Lewis
live at the Troubadour go baby 13th Zach
Lewis live at the Troubadour January
13th
those tickets still available so just
saying they're going fast they're going
fast
grab them quick
not that fast clearly not that fast
uh you know what uh
um that's gonna be a fun show it's gonna
be really fun Joe I'm just kidding
exactly you're gonna sell out there's no
question about it do you know how many
tickets you've sold uh we're at uh 305 I
think out of 500 yeah that's nice that's
a good show that's a good show out yeah
yeah Troubadour Troubadour January 13th
how much is a ticket
um we're offering a uh VIP one for 50
and then General is 20. what does VIP
mean they get to meet you no it's like I
do an acoustic set before the show so
like they're getting two shows in one
you do a acoustic test except for the
VIPs yes and do they you guys do like
sit around in a circle
no not at Kumbaya we do like a four to
five song Set where it's a little more
intimate but like where do you guys meet
this is before the show how do you how
do you make sure that it's just for them
it's on the Troubadour stage so it's
like we know who purchased the VIP
tickets oh wait wait wait wait do they
get in before everyone else yes okay so
they get in early yes they get a little
Zach Lewis time one-on-one yes yeah well
you can take you're gonna be wearing
anything the opportunity to meet Zach
Lewis that's that's it's more about the
acoustic show than anything you should
charge more than 50 for that to meet
Zach in person
I'm feeling 200 for that well
still just trying to sell the normal
weapons right now
oh that's fun that's so cool yeah uh
listen guys
uh trying to get over this crazy Life
Sale thing uh oh yeah Our member podcast
went up yesterday
so that's it that's the first episode
now all members we're trying to bolster
the members and appreciate the members
Tuesday is now going to be the fifth
podcast of the week for Members Only
and actually
we wanted to take a poll on the title
because we were a little bit conflicted
so there was lots of people recommending
and I agree that this is a great title
see you next Tuesday
mm-hmm
great title there was some concern back
here in the office that is interesting
that like in five years you know you
never know how these kind of words
evolved then five years people be like
yo this dude had a
this dude had a podcast that was called
see you next Tuesday he's a misogynist
piece of [ __ ] but that happened is that
reasonable no
no uh I was the one who voiced that
concern all I can say is I remember back
in the day there was a little man named
Daniel Keem who had an organization
called the Federation of [ __ ] Gamers
with a very epic acronym
um that was very in you know in 2009
humor uh everyone thought was very funny
and now that gets thrown in his face all
the time and uh just don't want that to
happen to you uh five to ten years
because well like and I guess the reason
is because YouTube gets super pissed
when we say that word so and they
consider like I hate word so I'm like
hmm is this something that's happening I
don't know but you guys can help us vote
because they're the other one that was
more
potentially
unproblematic was playing with myself
yeah way better
well it's not no I know it is it's not a
hate crime at least if you're doing it
privately yes you know in the comfort
and
safety of your home so let's do a vote
see you next Tuesday or playing with
myself
there was another one was there not we
said Ethan Unleashed but I don't know
those are the two I like personally see
you next Tuesday and it's just spelled
just like playing up no no see you spell
it out
you know so it's just the two options
we're doing in between I'm just yeah you
need to pull in that case
uh what and this should the title be see
you next Tuesday and sorry the other
people love Ethan Unleashed it's funny
it's so corny and it's funny but
you guys don't want to see me unleash
man was it trust me the NRA does not
want to see me unleash you know what I'm
saying do you see it oh my God keep me
chained up man trust me
so see you next Tuesday playing with
myself we're not Ethan Unleashed not
even an option no
because you're not even I'm not at least
trust me man you if you unleash me I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do life in prison
all right so I'm gonna throw it up with
just these two options here we here we
go
what should the title be see you next
Tuesday playing with myself ask your
community
yeah thank you guys
um
you know I think they're both really
good so it's kind of hard to decide uh
for me
but
lots of really really nice comments it
was so nice to read the comments and
actually they're all fupa Troopers
there's no haters I mean there's not
haters really our comment section is
usually pretty great these days but
oh
yes Sam just confirmed we are sold out
wow look at that that's [ __ ] oh okay
that's amazing
that's crazy man you guys are you guys
are wild for that thank you guys [ __ ]
that is overwhelmingly nice you guys
thank you so much
that was so nice thank you thank you
you're cool about the members podcast
too Ethan is I'm looking at the views
and the views are just a little bit
higher than the amount of members that
we have which I noticed almost everybody
checked it out yeah that's almost like a
hundred percent yeah watch rate that's
great thank you thank you yeah it's
super cool
um
so anyway yeah okay so see you next
Tuesday's the winner yeah I mean that
title is just so good it's on Tuesday
it's see you next Tuesday I'm dropping
c-bombs Ethan's basement
that's actually where it's recorded
right
that's pretty funny oh [ __ ]
all right so there it is so that's the
type in my basement all right I'm ending
the poll yes so if you want access to
that uh become a member basically oh but
but we're still doing four great
episodes a week and uh
nothing really changes so thank you guys
oh is this a new thumbnail design you
came up with there yeah I just wanted
something I like this cam made it for me
I just wanted to do something a
thumbnail so that people can see it
right they'll recognize it when they see
it what it is that's a great thumb I
like it yeah this thanks
as always
hitting Legends yeah hitting it right
let's get let's move on to some fun
stuff now
um but thank you so much everyone wow
that's crazy I want to tell you uh let
the conversation be I'll uh I'll send in
our group chat room look for my damn
phone it's there
yeah I want to know what ELO thinks
about that we sold out in like 30
seconds [ __ ] [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] I
guess you guys I guess we do have fans I
didn't know I was never sure stay out
there
well if you guys want to read hate
comments just go to the highlights
Channel those are [ __ ] insane pull
one up right now pull it up just pull up
a random here I'll pull it up because so
people can see
do I have that plug-in where you can see
that like dislike because that I can
tell you sure yeah tell me give me a
good juicy one from recently well I mean
I'd go to any undertake video probably
no but not even Tate is like cheating I
want like
okay
uh Peterson oh that's cheating too
obviously Everyone Hates Me by the way
we have a super chat from a fan in Saudi
Arabia based off of the currency that
sentence about whoa 58
um but they say YouTube memberships are
not available in my country and it's
killing me that there's content history
content I can't access that's uh that
does suck okay so someone actually I
forget was it UAB yeah that's an
interesting idea that we make a patreon
for people who don't have access to
membership so that they have a way of
getting access to their way to like sync
that with the YouTube membership you
think
well I guess the patreon wouldn't have
any content that the other one doesn't I
think there would be a way so that they
get access to the Discord and everything
there please sign up it's interesting
something to think about I mean I wonder
if it's not available in these countries
would patreon be available it's just
saying get a VPN I think you can be I
think you can be executed for that in
Saudi Arabia
you know doubtful expressvpn.com H3
yeah why don't just get a VPN go to
express.expressvpn.com because I don't
want to make a patreon because then all
these [ __ ] little hater ass [ __ ]
would be like this millionaire is
begging for money from his fans
yeah I see it you know it's gonna happen
I mean we're already
it's really not that different than them
built in so it's less yeah that that is
nice dude sons of [ __ ] yeah all right
let me just click here uh the Adam
Levine drama just got worse let's see is
let's see
oh actually these are I feel like if
it's something like that it's not gonna
be that bad it's always going to be the
ones that are about like Jordan Peterson
or something like that yeah actually all
right let's do the Peterson one yo yeah
that one's Gonna Be Epic actually we
have a new Jordan Peterson video for
today no we're crying I actually I put
it in for tomorrow's show but we can we
can watch I put it in today as well
yes here it is Ethan making fun of
Jordan's benzo addiction is a new low
yes making fun of mental health wow
Ethan do they have a point
should we not make fun of his benzo
addiction
uh [ __ ] him but it's so funny that he
only eats meat like I mean he's addicted
to benzos
and but he was so takes his house so
seriously and then he's shelling this
meat-only diet
it's like bro eat some broccoli
that might help
is so horrible I mean also also I just
want to say
this is a self-help Guru he's given
everyone the answers on how to live
their lives see to me that's the irony
it's not like oh what a loser he's an
addict it's why do you sit
up high and wag your finger at everybody
and tell everybody how to live their
lives when your life is in shambles
exactly
yeah
yeah so I'm just trying I think it's
okay in this case you know
also I mean the whole story is
incredible the man went to Russia got
some experimental [ __ ] his daughter was
[ __ ] cruising around Europe with
Andrew Tate literally
come on guys put them in an induced Como
right they wouldn't do a coma he came
out like a Sith Lord bro you went in
they did some like dark fifth Alchemy
they're doing the dark arts yeah they
did some [ __ ] because he came out like
on the dark side man it's a pathway to
many abilities
uh Ethan calling someone not smart is
comical are you not are you saying I'm
not smart Alex Alex
it's Martin you dude
Ethan should debate Jordan Ethan will
get wrecked though I
believe we invited him to come on
if Ashley thinks that they can slander
Someone Like Jordan Peterson who the
[ __ ] is listening to this dribble oh he
said dribble he's smart dribble
rip the good Ethan smarter than you do I
really wish YouTube still showed the
amount of dislikes oh potato in the chat
says as a benzo addict you get a pass so
we got the benzos
Jordan didn't say anything wrong here in
fact he was absolutely right in his
assessment okay genius
okay
seeing this guy called Peterson dumb is
beyond hilarious if he lost one more
brain cell the other one would die of
loneliness
there you have it
uh the rage bait is awesome though
because these videos are actually
getting the most views right love of
anything else it's so easy to bait the
Jordan Peterson look at this
we're literally making money on them
it's the best thing ever and it's so
funny
yeah
what's what's still like dislike on this
oh you sent me yeah they're all below 30
on the Jordan oh that's real bad wait
where do you see it on this no I just
he's seeing on the back of thumb or the
the title is so easy to just bait them
and me me and love had a uh conversation
recently we're like let's jack up the
[ __ ] rage bait even harder to like 11
because it's just so satisfying to make
money from them yeah it's so good wait
show me one of those yeah the dislikes
yeah let me see that
I'll just show you the dislikes
by the way this black cherry flavor goes
so hard
somebody in the chat said the dude who
commented at the top has over 300
Channel comments meaning he's commented
on the highlights how do they see that I
think there's extensions where you can
oh my God I'm dying to see those I want
to see those so bad that's a good catch
I need that
if you're on your phone you can see that
if you're on your phone you can but I
believe it only shows the two most
recent ones right love it's like only a
couple it shows all the one yeah I think
it shows a total though yeah it shows
the total but the actual comments
themselves I think it only shows a
couple but yeah it is useful yeah this
is like a million views we farmed from
Jordan Peterson fans 17 like ratio let's
go dude 17. yes 71
000 views that's got to be one of the
worst we've ever had that's exclusive
haters
[Laughter]
they always think it's like you Ethan
who's like bathing them on rage bathing
stuff but it's me just some random dude
in Sweden
I can't sort for dislikes for some
reason
so then this one has 120 000 likes
that's just money in the bank 25 luck
ratio oh yeah you know what I mean
so I salute you uh tater tots peterheads
benzo boys
Ela just replied by the way she said
it's so exciting she's blown away that
you're sold out that quickly yeah that
is really fun thank you guys you guys
really made my day here and just made me
feel real loved and also afraid that
somebody's gonna kill me and wear my
skin you already asked them not to
I don't know if I polite all the
scenarios though because I said don't
kill me and consume my soul don't think
you're not going to become Me by killing
me I feel like there's other ones where
people be like I'm reincarnated as what
about like dismemberments but like
non-fatal
don't cut it off like an ear or like a
hand or something yeah don't do that
either okay
you can't sacrificing a piece of my body
into a black magic arts or some [ __ ] is
not gonna [ __ ] bring Jordan Peterson
back
from the Dark Side what's the poison
that all of the Russian dissidents uh
get
it's like Palladium or something like
that
so by the way
yo this channel is our number one hater
he has he has
283 comments this is the guy who's
putting Theodore through college
you alone are
yeah
look at these comments again Ethan
talking about a topic he virtually knows
nothing about H3 has declined into l3l
at this point Ethan has fallen so much
since 2017. dude you're like full you're
like a part-time uh hater man maybe full
time
oh my God I love you so much
kryptum
shout out
yeah if you guys can find one less than
19 I'd love to see it
um there's a couple exactly around 19
but that might actually be seems to be
the floor and it's like this the speed
that's you know what I mean like you
like you can't go over the speed of
light you can't go below 90 likes it's
just not possible yeah
that's how I roll I have one speed I
have one gear go right
um before we uh move on we are at 32
minutes if you wanted to uh shout out
shout out the family yes yes yes uh
where were we
how did we get there what are we [ __ ]
talking about oh the the highlights
Channel whatever
um yeah liver King's coming tomorrow
finally
I've been trying to get this guy in here
I feel like me and Hassan were early
adopters what's up the liver King he's
become so popular though this man is
kind of
and he's an icon I love
this guy and he's a genius marketer I'm
not even gonna take that from him this
guy started posting stories yesterday
thanking me and Hassan
for for gardening
his private jet uh-huh oh so funny
actually wait are these in order
oh yeah here it is watch Hassan texted
me right after the show
and he's like did you buy uh
did you buy a liver King a private jet
I was like I didn't spend one penny on
this man
and so he he told me that liver King was
doing some [ __ ] on Instagram but it's
super funny here it is
podcast it was H3 right yeah they sent
me a private jet to come on their
podcast so we're headed over to the
airport to see how big it is if it's a
small jet guess what
we're not even gonna get on but if it's
a big jet we're talking 10 seats plus
capacity never King and liver Queen are
coming next stop the private jet I'm a
king out damn dude Liberty out yeah and
so of course we did get him that
10-seater he's tagging us on all of them
off the couch seven eight nine and ten
that'll do
you know what though this guy's bawling
so [ __ ] hard clearly holy [ __ ] you
know how much it costs a charter a jet
like that across the country I mean
hundreds of thousands that much yeah I
would have guessed like 20 grand or
something like that hundreds of
thousands I was talking to a friend I
don't know I was talking to a friend he
wanted to Charter a jet to go on
vacation from LA to Hawaii
I was like how much is it you wanted to
split it with me
and he's like it's a hundred thousand
dollars I said [ __ ] that I said
absolutely [ __ ] no dude
and uh that's about the same length
what's up Larry King damn yeah I mean
okay he is bawling that supplement game
is something man
one two three here uh thank you HD for
the job I love this picture so much well
and then what was funny is he started
rage baiting a lot of people like
there's fans of ours who are like big
into environmentalism or
[Music]
who are like oh he's such a hypocrite
and people were really eating the onion
on this one
I see some people in the chat saying
they they believe that yeah I mean check
it out about one luxury vehicle but two
luxury Vehicles
going on here is he [ __ ] with me I
think he just thinks it's funny it is
funny yeah no he's just joking with me
okay
uh and then here
the private jet is bougie enough but
check this out let's check it out H3 put
us up at the Beverly Wilshire
apparently they upgraded us from a
regular regular human-sized room to the
penthouse suite now I don't know if this
is actually true but rumor has it that a
place like this with a wrap-around
balcony cost thirty thousand dollars a
night what kind of gift what Primal 100
believe that's the price he's paying for
that probably holy [ __ ] everything goes
hard man I think it was funny he's
coming tomorrow he's bringing his chef
yeah are you excited to try all this
stuff no but I will I'm going now maybe
it'll surprise me I mean I don't even
like cooked liver but whatever I'll do
it
do you think he'll be able to like just
smell on me that I don't eat meat and
like call me out you know what we should
try to have him guess the vegetarian
do that write that down let's see if he
can spot it well they seem to be doing
the research so he might he might know
but
uh Jasmine said I wish I could have
gotten tickets
do more Live Events you guys are the
best uh thank you so much Jasmine my my
goal is to do one a month basically
after this uh or work up to it anyway I
was gonna say
I thought we had said like two to three
months but or once a quarter maybe I
don't know we'll see how it goes I mean
we were waiting to see how this first
one does but I mean the fact it sold out
so fast
seems promising so it might become a
regular thing A Part my concern is just
like if how impact how much impact does
it have on my
week
or slash life because if it's like
relatively low impact then we can
definitely do it uh
and for you guys too every every month
um
but liver King is out there yeah it's
gonna be a lot of fun we've got some
boobs planned
you think he would arm wrestle Hassan
that's something is just something we're
work we're working on that was something
we have uh listed as one of our
activities tomorrow yeah we're gonna see
because you know Hassan's a strong man
but liver King is I mean a God yeah
also super low Center gravity you think
we could get them to wrestle because
he's a beefy boy low to the ground
you know
I guess we'll see but there it is gonna
be a lot of fun
also you
he goes
by the way thank you for Bella fifty
dollars for Ethan's private jet fund
thank you
thank you very good
he goes he I don't know if I'm gonna if
I should say this but it's funny you're
gonna regret it
about what he asked us today
it's not that bad it's funny okay
you think I'll shouldn't say it no I
wasn't even sure what you're gonna say
but anytime you're like I probably
shouldn't say this is funny it's funny
he I mean I know he's you know
he wants to promote and he asks us
actually what he did was really
professional nice he asked us if he
could buy an ad spot to do a full promo
for his um supplements and I was like
this [ __ ] is always selling I
love it and I you know I felt bad I'm
like I'm not going to charge you for a
spot you're my guest right you know you
spent like 200 000 to come here
apparently
so I said you just do your spot just
keep it to a minute and you can sell you
can do all the organs and [ __ ] and
whatever you want to do but I just love
that he's such a character man I gotta
say yeah yeah it was and I feel like
that's the right call because I feel
like there's next to no chance you'll be
able to resist goofin on it a little bit
and if he's not paying for it then in
the bet in the sweetest piece in love
way possible yeah exactly but like you
know it's gonna be a peace and love uh
uh interview but I will say that you
know most people just come and like plug
plug plug but the fact that he's like yo
let me pay for a spot Class Act to be
honest
real quick
um Chad's asking where Olivia is she's
out of town for the week she'll be back
on Monday
um
bro right I meant to say that at the top
sorry for not mentioning that earlier
Olivia's out of town for the week
but we do have your tank a prized moment
to cherish her while she's gone this one
of course if it gifted thank you very
good
this one you guys probably already heard
20 times today
but it's very good
very good all right so let's think we
have one sponsor let's thank them okay
and
um we'll get back into the fun stuff
here we've sponsored by Ray Harry's
yes it's Harry razors folks
what do you got going on you going back
to school you're going to a wedding
you're preparing for a holiday party
it's cut to the chase it's time to clean
up
incredibly sharp razors with refills
that arrive on the nick of time every
time Harris is the official sponsor of
cutting it close baby
Harry's freaking rules they got these
weighty handles just like 10 blade I
don't know how many blades it's got but
it's one of those I think it's I think
it's four not quite ten yeah
well at a certain point it's just
ridiculous I mean how many blades do you
need four that's enough that's Max
and man I've had one in my shower that
mean Ela share
I just I use it on the back of my neck I
like to do that to keep my neck clean
um
we have it in there like for so long and
it never gets dull it's pretty
incredible
the price is insane
the shave is high quality
and then they got this body wash that
smells like a dream
uh it's all happening right now you can
get Harry's starter set for just three
bucks plus you'll get a free travel
sized body wash
the set includes a five five blade bro
you said four dude it's five Weasley
little liar dude I'm so sorry five
freaking blades I'm so sorry yep
he's got five blade razor weighted
handle foaming shave gel and a travel
cover it's a 16 value for just three
bucks guys you know it's a good
opportunity to try it see if you like it
but you will love it it's harry's.com
slash H3
um
did you know that Harry Stars has uh uh
Harry Stardust that starts at three
bucks and the refill Blazers lows two
bucks each delivered straight to your
door
you could stop spending money on razors
that are overpriced yeah dude what's the
deal with Razer prices you've been in
the grocery store she's like oh yeah oh
yeah
why it's a joke
it is absolutely infuriating but no no
matter how busy things get stay fresh
with Harry's get your hairies starter
set today and you'll also get a free
travel size body wash just go to
harrys.com H3 that's harrys.com H3 thank
you to Harry
Mr Harry
[Music]
hey okay let's go
let's get him okay
okay let's go
[Music]
so okay
um
where were we I there's so much good
stuff at the top of the show
uh this shit's gonna blow your tits
right off
this a b find
there's a lot of ancient a b finds I'm
I'm learning we had this one is very
good though
I don't know how somebody found this
um
5000 points on the server people were
captivated by this one
now you want to give us some background
here a young uh Abdullah yes uh this was
like my first year of college and uh
clearly I'm super nervous
and I say um after every word I can't
make eye contact it's a good time I
actually thought you were you were
pretty articulate I think you sounded
like pretty confident in my opinion I
have mixed feelings about this because
on one hand it's super cringe but on the
other hand this is it shows that I was
on the right side of History 10 years
ago so proud of that yeah that's true
actually yeah liberal King by the way
loving the spikes man I don't know what
the bike [ __ ] that was it man what year
was it
this way is 2011.
for 2012. it's like said died by that I
think that feels a little I was about to
back you up here but I feel like spikes
were not actually again but Twilight was
very popular around that time okay well
maybe they had spikes and they might
have comment on hair what the [ __ ] doing
no they weren't releasing you don't even
have hair
um
but okay at loving the strap you still
have that let me see you I don't have
anything I'm growing it back but did you
have this before the little chin yeah
you know what I didn't know that was a
weird thing until I moved out of my
hometown because a lot of dudes because
we're primarily Arab there have just
that the chin dip what do you call that
all right I know my dad has I just
calling my dad's a beard I don't know
call that the new metal is that true
Lena you think everyone rocks the chin
dip there it is common in Dearborn yeah
come to a California baby we got all
kinds of beard styles blow your mind out
here
anyway here he is
a b
whiten his eyes in a vision
an unshakable Vision I had the honor to
meet with the director of political
action Mr Abdullah ayad good evening
good evening thank you for having me
it's indeed a very great event tonight
and could you please explain to the
audience what kind of political
connection or position do you do at the
organization as director of political
action I get um sounds like you're
running for office bro
I'm talking completely out of my ass I
was ambushed you know for real
yeah I wasn't expected to be interviewed
I was completely ambushed yeah this lady
just walked over to me in my dad said
here interview him oh are you did you
have aspirations of running for office
because this is very this is a political
young man now my family's just involved
in politics my dad and my uncle were
both awarded at this dinner
um so yeah did you get an award no I was
given the award oh sure yeah
I'll give you an award now can we get an
ambient award major award I appreciate
that thank you major Awards they got
all right I don't know if you can find
out I can just I can give you a sort of
certificate like number one simp or
something I don't know no okay
I wanted to give you like a king of
political action Awards oh director of
political action yeah yeah it was great
I didn't know [ __ ] about politics I
always made director of political action
that's so awesome not only the ASU but
other uh Youth of the community involved
in politics we get them involved in
elections and uh other other things to
help prepare them to you know to educate
them so that they're not taking
advantage of by uh any any form of
system or anything against Arabs oh
um my dad is um he is uh Lebanese
yeah how do I know that's what she meant
because when I heard background I
thought maybe she was talking about like
educational
or so that's where my mind went yeah I
thought if I just keep talking
everything would be okay I don't even
know maybe she met my background in
politics I don't I don't know yeah okay
interesting but you're like 19. it was
like what how much background could you
have yeah I don't know I I was the
treasurer of the student body right and
I always ask me like I don't look Arab
so I guess that's what I assumed I see I
see
can I be a little bit honest you looked
more Arab back then than you do know
it's the chin strap baby yeah but maybe
that's why I had it I wanted to fit in
um on the bleached hair you don't want
to fit in yo you with your fingers and
your chin beard
do you go to school
um yes I go to the University of
Michigan Dearborn what's your major
um I'm majoring in Psychology but going
into medicine so how how are you in
medicine how's that how did that work
out
everything happened to work out so it
works out great it worked out great
after this I had really fun 10 years
after this and I got my dream job now so
it's got a little [ __ ] doctors yeah
I could call him car show and ruin your
life yep
anyways son are we going for medicine at
the same time you are being involved in
political action
um my dad's very politically involved my
dad is an attorney he's uh serves on a
lot of community organizations um he's
the chairman of the board of the acrl
the American Civil Rights League that's
actually pretty badass that your dad's
on the ACLU
yeah good for him it's a good background
to have
come from good good folks yeah my dad
didn't have a father and he was taking
advantage a lot when he was younger um
and he faced a lot of discrimination so
he looked up a lot to like Martin Luther
King and Malcolm X got heavily involved
in civil rights and became a civil
rights attorney so and started that
organization
that's awesome man yeah shout out to
Pops my dad sold bikes for a living so I
don't know
that's a cool job
cartoons is dope well I was
I was still trashed
in the grand scheme of things it's not
as important as fighting for civil
rights you know what I mean it's cool
though
yo by the way speaking of a b the public
freakout video made it to or made it to
public freak out actually this is like
front page Reddit 7 000 points this is
kind of Awesome
and by the way
you've been having a really hard time
reaching Marriott right
yeah I've reached out to them multiple
times I keep getting the run around and
they have never once reached out to me
like they haven't even sent me an email
saying they got my email they they I've
talked to two different managers and no
response but yesterday they definitely
responded after seeing this
um just sent me a tweet oh they did I
mean Twitter DM and so that they
couldn't deal with me because my name
wasn't on the reservation the person who
made the reservation had to talk to them
which was who which was Lena's sister
who I had reach out and then said that I
have permission to talk on behalf of
myself yeah it's not like a doctor's
office and then they said they'll get
back to me and that's it so we'll see I
find it kind of incredible that it was
so hard to report this guy to warned
them about this guy yeah I really do I
mean I figure you just go to the front
desk and be like yo this guy
being like violent towards me and it was
funny we mentioned before but when we're
leaving the structure and we were
telling the attendant who was working uh
he was like oh it was or she was like
Mark oh yeah that's Mark like like he's
done this before like he has a
reputation of being a Nutty
here for you those of you who are not
familiar
you got it real funny huh
we're leaving right now sir no that he
had such a delayed reaction on the real
funny because you laughed like five
seconds before and in that moment when I
stopped
the best way I could describe it if
you're familiar with Chappelle Show when
uh Charlie Murphy was talking about when
he fought Rick James and Rick James got
his face and he stopped for a second he
goes one one part of my mind I'm like
well this is Rick James he's a famous
celebrity but my hood side tell me
you'll stomp this [ __ ] up right
now all right that's exactly how I felt
but because I had the girls I was like
let's just go to the car well actually
the comments were super supportive of
you everyone's like this guy uh is a
king for being polite yeah I like
whoever made it actually a lot of people
are saying I expected different from a
YouTuber yeah and I was pleasantly
surprised you may be the first YouTuber
ever to make it to public freak out
and not be the dick so congratulations
that was awesome yeah I'm honored that
they even referred to me as a YouTuber
uh whoever posted this but very cool yo
here's another one
he's very mature and tried to calm the
situation down that's the second comment
what is with skateboarding and all
people I agree what the [ __ ] man that
act like skateboards are radioactive
um a b please stand up there's a fupa
Trooper oh here's another one normally
when I see influencers vloggers on here
I'm happy to see them shut down but this
guy handled it perfectly
said sorry God is bored and moved on
that old man was a dick hmm
yeah it was nice reading these comments
because like I said I went back and
forth for a while like should I have
done something but there were a few
comments saying though that it's mean of
us to want this employee to get punished
or fired or whatever they're going to do
which is crazy because like
something needs to happen no other
customer or person should feel like that
like how he made us feel it was honestly
traumatizing
yeah I mean and the fact that I was with
them like imagine the girls were alone
um
I don't know it's just a bad situation I
don't I don't think you're on a crusade
to get them fired you just want to
respond so you just want someone to yeah
knowledge yeah that you made a complaint
for Christ's sake
well there it is the whole saga
continues to uh
unravel there on the internet
you know
good times should we bring out the um
the Big Brother guy
if he's not ready I got plenty more to
do you can't be ready yeah let me uh I
need to pee because I've been chugging
this Gamers up
so you guys want to set that up and I'll
be right back okay
okay be right back
sorry I'm in the middle of chewing
everyone I'm just down some circus
animal cookies what'd you get are you
guys white or pinks pink baby come on
pink pink
I'm Arab in my mom's Caucasian
you know I don't know I'm messing around
I I like them equally same
[ __ ] fence Center you serious anybody
else want to weigh on this what what
pain I personally I'm white
we know we know you're white Dan
it's very funny but what color animal
are you you like
very funny Zachary
he's a funny guy he's a funny guy I
missed it what are you saying you don't
like the pink flavor no I like them both
but I just I lean towards the white ones
yeah me too yeah I tend to notice when
things are flavored in that way like on
cupcakes or icing and stuff the colored
ones always taste kind of weird have
like a weird aftertaste I could not
agree more it seems like the chat is
against us though I'm seeing far more
pinks than whites in the chat far more
pinks actually people saying that people
saying they're the same
are you [ __ ] insane here's the thing
they're not the same yeah the pinks are
very unique I feel like it's a very
unique cookie it is a unique flavor I'll
give you that and I don't dislike it
don't get me wrong
I'm not saying I'm not hating on the
pink I just I lean towards the lights
I hate this candy
Ian Ian
Ian thoughts
what
what are your thoughts on this
discussion that we're having
about cookies
[ __ ] circus animal cookies Ian so no
cookies for you
I know you have an opinion on this
uh oh the white ones yeah I'm a white
guy shut the [ __ ] up take this seriously
I like cookies I'm white
why don't you go back to terrorizing
Florida Jesus Christ
anyone make that joke
does anyone make that uh race joke yeah
I said and then Zach immediately said it
after me a third time's the chart yeah
I'm eating an apple
good for you Captain that's what I'm
shut up I like uniced
oh that's the chaotic no icing no Icing
at all do you like scrape it off with a
knife
I I mean I would but I don't really
think it's scrapable on those
so no uh cookies feeling fully immersed
it's nice Zach I'm back Ethan yeah
what's the question pink or white
you know man it's been a decade since I
had one of those but I think pink let's
go for the color you know last five I
mean they're fun they're fun you're not
wrong about that but can I do they are
they not the same flavor they're
slightly different oh you can definitely
like if if you've blindfolded me I could
tell you which ones which you could I
think so well guys test this right now
close your eyes so well there's no one
feet somebody has to go get him that's a
challenge bro that was the trunk
s yeah I think now now I'm laid down the
gauntlet the pink ones invoke in me a
more festive feeling okay you know it's
scary it's exciting
white is just
white is just White
and close my eyes close your eyes okay
put the hot chip in his mouth yeah
please please don't be the hot chick all
right here we go
Dan has put the first cookie into his
mouth that's white
okay is that right yeah you're right
they taste a little different they do
they're gonna do it again
white by white boy
oh you're gonna do it again I mean you
got it right there's only two of them
get the [ __ ] out of here
wait did you really open it baby no you
just had an old one package because we
still have one of those hot chips left
and someone gonna eat that I'm just
saying
just saying and Dan you're the only one
that didn't try it
uh yeah what was your excuse again
because you're a diary oh I was sick
that day like legitimately my stomach
was I was already [ __ ] up you feel now
I feel fine but I the moments passed
that's it
now it's always a good moment for a hike
no moments passed
um actually are we getting this guy on
the line did he say he's coming uh yeah
joining right now all right he actually
just jumped into the waiting room I want
to watch this uh uh just it's real fast
and it's related to The Hot Chip
I've been obsessed with this since we
tried it and there's a bunch of them on
tick tock
and the result is usually people are
super confident
for about the first 30 seconds you're
like this ain't [ __ ] this ain't even
spicy
and then oh my God liver King should he
do you think he would do it
I don't think it's like processed food I
don't it's not Prime oh it's like I
think he only eats like but maybe pain
is Primal no way he'll do it I yeah I
feel like he won't do it
you're gonna ask but that's a good point
maybe we just need it maybe we just need
to get a raw I don't think he eats like
anything processed like Carolina Reaper
tomorrow morning yeah I don't know if
that's like just readily available no
it's not anyway so
usually people lose their [ __ ] after 30
seconds and are just completely
debilitated but leave it to abuela
and you know she cooks spicy food oh
yeah abuela you're always throwing those
Habaneros in those jalapenos
when you sent this as soon as I opened
it I'm like oh I know what this video is
dude she is the spicy chip Champion I've
never seen anyone do it like her
thank you
this woman was born in this place
first of all she's taking tiny little
bite she's savoring
that to me seems like the worst way to
do it
she just snacking on that thing man
around
my channel
she's chewing it down I think the heat
should start hitting her now on this
first bite oh she's feeling it
do little bites okay he's letting it sit
on the tongue too
yeah most people are on the ground by
now
the craziest part is up next
foreign
oh and rubbing on her lips for Christ's
sake why would you even do that
yeah
[Music]
the finger licking blows my mind man how
does that make you feel baby I've seen
that I don't know I'm just thinking
about how bad my lips burned they were
burning for a while
her lips are blue
who licks their fingers yeah it ended
there I kind of wish it went longer but
I just thought that was so impressive
she's definitely
The Undefeated Champion oh here there's
a part two hello guys we don't have part
to but we'll make another video today
once I get off work
come on bro why are you leaving us
hanging
this vid this one has six hundred
thousand this dumbass video everyone
wants to see the follow-up
hello guys we don't have part to but
we'll make another video today once I
get off work how are we gonna do me like
that all right anyway shout out abuela
you are
chip Champion all right let's bring on
our guest let's just real quick did we
show this yet no I just cam made this
for UAB so just congratulations thank
you thank you actually you know what's
funny real quick I was actually running
I forgot I ran for president the next
year and I won
the biggest on-campus organization thank
you thank you thank you wow yeah the uh
Award of course is the director of
political action
certified
this certificate is presented to
Abdullah a ayad and then of course the
uh text underneath says lorem ipsum
this is simply dummy tax it's in Latin
so you know it's fancy
oh is it Latin
I thought it was meaningless yeah
if Einstein had an ugly family member
someone said of me in the tater tot chat
thank you guys I appreciate that I'm
smart
in a way in a roundabout way
anyway let's bring on our guest okay
yeah I will
let him in right now a little bit of a
background here on uh the friend calling
in a friend of the show already good guy
Ethan okay hey dude
dude what's going on
we have a big brother third place
runner-up Matt Turner
yo yo what is up
um
you know what happened bro why didn't
you get first man you're you gotta rep
like you let that hassanabi head win
that's some [ __ ] well dude that's a
good question but I'm with the guy who
evicted me right here so oh
no but it's all good I mean dude I'm
super excited to be on the show I've
been a huge fan since I was like in high
school like five six seven years ago so
hell yes dude oh thank you so much I
appreciate that and actually
what I loved watching was
um Matt during the show there's like
four Clips I have of you referencing the
show which is so funny and awesome one
of them is when you have got your buddy
there trying to say Clarence kleinwater
oh dude yes I oh my God I still don't
even know it either is it is it Clarence
clean water it's Clarence Klein water oh
dude look at the part of the Klein water
has let's go yeah um these ones are so
they copyright these claims this [ __ ]
that's so whack I want to show them some
big Network shows online
when you shut it in left in uh leftovers
I think you watched it for a sec did you
guys get claimed actually no I don't
think I don't think we did actually here
is on
you guys are talking about leftovers
podcast uh she however she just never
watched that so I mean she's kind of a
fake fan dude you know I had to shout
out the fupa Troopers she was only a fan
of Hassan and our name was leftovers
like our alliance name I had to bring up
my boy Ethan bro it meant so much to me
watch this here this is from Big Brother
here I'm just making really small
that [ __ ] up the detection sometimes
or now it's not even loading I also have
a hard time detecting of it it doesn't
play all right let me refresh that's a
that's a Twitter uh for you Twitter I
mean it's Twitter boy here it is here it
is
and I'm just gonna do this
[Music]
uh called leftovers leftovers
oh it's a really good political podcast
yeah um it's just like you know left if
you know whoever I'm following that's
what's up dude
a really good oh I got you dude love
that and then here this one actually
cracked me up you talking about Clarence
climb water I could see you in your head
being like is this possible to explain
or dude I know I was like it's too far
gone I I don't know how to then I don't
even know when the feeds and what's
being shown I was like I don't think
this is ever going to be seen by anybody
so this is my first time seeing it oh
really yeah
so here it is
true
Credence Clearwater Revival oh another
from uh oh never mind I do know that
from here okay this group right yeah am
I saying the name right it's clean into
clear water it's always a clearance
clearance Clearwater it's not I thought
it was created okay listen yeah
in my head about this I listened to a
podcast and the whole joke about it is
that the host can never remember the
name so I'm [ __ ] the least reliable
person because I would have said
clearance clean water
yeah fairly confidence it sounds funny
when you uh when you uh talk about the
joke I think that's very good I mean
halfway through I was I didn't even know
if it was worth explaining I'm like dude
I don't know who cares
dude I tried bringing a bunch of Teddy
fresh into into the house but they
snagged it all
because it had a like a logo on it yeah
because I had a bunch of Frenemies stuff
I was like yeah
exactly I had all that and then I had
like a teddy fresh color block thing but
it was snag so I'm gonna rep it on
Instagram of course now that's that's
the next best thing I can do so what are
the what do you wear then do they give
you clothing to wear that doesn't have
logos on it oh no you just have to do
like no logos like this I I picked this
out specifically because I like H3 Vibes
but I could wear this in the house
there's not a logo on it I'll just [ __ ]
like that by the way here here it is uh
here is Matt making a frenemy's rug oh
let's go so once I do the backing off
camera we are left with this beautiful
piece
yeah that's kind of dope actually that's
really cool thank you I mean I won't say
Trisha shouted that out and was my first
ever person to like shout out my
Instagram and stuff so okay
Queen Behavior yeah
uh are you still following uh the Trisha
Arc are you like uh are you part of the
H3 Nation or you can do both
oh well I will say um like every single
more like before the house because I've
I've been in the Big Brother house for
the past like 100 days or so so every
single morning usually I wake up and I
watch the latest H3 so um yeah yeah
that's I'm part of the H3 Nation
okay all right love that do you watch uh
Trisha ASMR or no do you get into that
dude who is the who's the other lady who
would break the crab legs I remember you
guys watching that d uh her name was uh
Dede what was her name oh no I don't
think it was DD I remember who you're
talking about though DD Mega not DD Mega
dude
these just I love seeing this [ __ ] uh
here you are bringing up white clock
Gabe as your favorite uh tick tocker and
of course there's no other answer for
that there is it there really is the
number one
number two is white clock Gabe today I
bring
who I love he's my favorite do you know
why Clark Taylor do you hey
dumb but they're so funny he's like this
older probably like 50.
um
there's like Hawaiian and he goes [ __ ]
yeah maybe it's Friday [ __ ] yeah
you just can't explain that you have to
be there
dude is it like fried chicken Wednesday
right now oh God it is Fried Chicken
Wednesday oh hell yeah
also I want to say I'm from um right
next to where Cam grew up so I was dude
I don't know on the show cam shout out
cam shout out Cameron
so tell me you know tell me about the
Big Brother experience
um
what is it like being so you're in
isolation for like 30 days you don't
have the phone you don't have the laptop
right
well we're actually gone for more like a
hundred days I think our season was 80
85 days or something and then we're
sequestered for 15 days before that in a
hotel so we have no connection to the
outside world we kind of get our phone
strip and then we have competitions to
whoever stays the entire summer
um which I which I did which was dope um
whoever stays the entire summer went
750k and basically it's just like a
social experiment to cut you out from
the entire outside world you don't see
your family don't get a phone don't get
anything other than big brother
when you came out was there anything
that shocked you about what happened in
the world while you were gone
I mean I heard the queen died R.I.P
ripped to the great one dude the real
thing that all I was wondering was I
wanted to see what the H3 nation was up
to and I want to watch therapy Gekko
that's all I do yeah good guy good
choices dude I know so and then I heard
the only I mean I'm very like gen Z so I
was more focused on the YouTubers I
watched than Casey neistat moved to New
York so that is the main thing the best
part is a b what did you think about
Casey moving back to New York no at this
point I kind of feel like he's avoiding
me he came on the show before I worked
here as soon as I moved to LA he moved
back to New York yeah it's all about you
don't kill him and wear his skin maybe
no no you're first
yeah uh you're the you're the guy I was
worried about coming to the live show no
oh God yeah other than that they don't
like fill you in when something in the
world happens
um so I kind of just had to find out
everything and then when you leave the
house I obviously saw just 16 faces for
an entire summer and then it dwindled
down so like every single human
interaction just feels like a Christmas
morning basically you know I wonder if
there was like a nuclear Annihilation if
they would tell you guys or just have
like a vault 22 situation you know what
I mean dude storage room and just just
yeah he's come out to an apocalyptic
hellscape
I'm gonna dude I mean that was that was
that was a fear bro I was up in the
upstairs Dr yeah no like I don't I don't
know yeah no I don't [ __ ] it one other
question I always wondered about when
people go away on reality shows for that
long do they they gotta pay you
something right like during that time
yeah what did they give you
um so you have a stipend of like I don't
even know if I can say I think I'm in an
NDA but it is between
um one thousand and one dollars and 999
dollars a week so keeping it as big as
possible so they get exactly a thousand
dollars I'm just kidding okay so they
give you like a thousand dollars a week
for your duration there yeah and that's
that's okay you know something just to
keep you floating that's not bad yeah
and then like the final five I'll get
prize earnings sorry there's a link
going overhead but uh and then the final
five we have prize earnings uh third
place makes ten thousand dollars on top
of their weekly earnings which was me
um so yeah we collected the bag let's go
get that bad baby yes sir which like
maybe maybe if the third like 10K to
750k I was like the third place get
raised a little bit maybe but it's okay
we made it yes so um there's one other
thing that blew my [ __ ] mind dude
obviously everybody heard about this
report it was a big story about like New
York Times did this write-up about how
Mr Beast was mistreating his employees
right yeah and then somebody told me
last night that you were one of the
people interviewed in that and I was
like oh my God how is that possible
that's so crazy because I would love to
talk to you about that regardless
if you're interested yeah yeah no I'm
definitely down to answer I I've been
removed from that situation for a while
but I do I do remember getting out of
the house and seeing people be like how
did like this person's story arc go to
this and I was like listen character
development baby so yeah any questions
you have about it I'm down to answer
it's just such a small world situation
but
basically what they wrote is that you
know in 2018 to 2019 you worked for Mr B
so it was it one year or two years you
worked for him
it was like it was less than a year so
it was just within the compound of 2018
2019. it was from like early 2018 to
like I don't know the fall of 2018.
and you were editing his videos did you
were you like one of many editors or
were you like the single editor how did
it work back then I think back then
there were like three editors and it was
really just a team of probably 10 people
Max so it was a small team I worked
there from like 3 million subscribers to
maybe 10.
wow it's crazy is it to blow your mind
the growth of that channel since you
left it's kind of insane isn't it oh did
he I was actually wondering did he
surpass like PewDiePie yet because I
know when I left he was on track he hit
100 Mil he's close I don't know what is
PewDiePie at these days he's close he's
definitely going to I'm checking right
now but yeah and I wish nothing because
obviously like it was a chaotic thing a
few years ago but I'm older now and I
was 18 at the time I'm 23 yeah God damn
I almost forgot my age um yeah I know so
but I wish all the best for the guy I
have no ill will towards anyone in that
space huge Is that real quick uh almost
112 a million and Mr Beast as 105
million wow wow
man I thought nobody could ever possibly
take PewDiePie that is why Amber was so
insane but there it is well dude this is
even more a niche but it wasn't when I
left I think cabbie Lane was about to
pass Charlie demilio and followers too
right I don't know if you guys are up to
date on that but yeah I thought that
happened recently
oh damn so they did pass I yeah I'm not
super familiar with the tick tock race I
got you but we get banned from there
every day so yeah I know I'm surprised
I'm surprised we're still live we've
gone live on Tick Tock like every day
the past couple weeks and I get
suspended every single time for either
bowling or or misinformation uh I'm
still tick tock's the feds what the hell
man that's right
so I but the thing was like yeah so in
the in the New York Times They said that
you alleged that it was a toxic work
environment and I think at the time that
that story came out
there was a lot of people
because I didn't know you I didn't know
anything about it came for you right
personally oh yeah dude I I received
probably for probably a year and a half
straight just like 10 000 messages a day
saying I was like clout chasing I was
like all right well this is not how I
wanted this to go but the stories out
there I told my side of it and I mean
obviously there's like a hundred million
12 year olds that watch him I don't know
what else I expected
but it um yeah it's kind of were you
kind of shocked like damn
these people want to believe so much
that he's like you know the patron saint
of YouTube and uh
it doesn't seem to me that you would
have any reason to lie about it and I
mean you're sharing your story but still
people like no one you became a villain
and I didn't know you I just remember I
was like oh wow everyone [ __ ] hates
this guy they're saying he's lying
they're saying he's clout chasing just
completely dismissed everything you said
oh totally and I mean the people like
obvious obviously like in a lot of
situations of course believe the victim
first because at what point would that
benefit my career or anything I had
doing and everyone was like oh dude he's
just doing this for clouds like what the
hell am I going to gain from this ever
at all other than hate so I never
understood that but then it was like you
had keemstar pushing the worst narrative
in the world oh what did he say about
you oh just he was like pushing the this
guy's a cloud chaser rhetoric and at
least then you had Philly D who was a
little more like in the middle I was
like we love that and then on the other
side we had Taylor Lorenz who was like a
saint and I love her because she her
like months on end was just like hey if
you ever need anything reach out and she
was like you know as much as a reporter
can do believing everything I said which
was like I love breath of fresh air at
that point and then one other person who
reported on it his name is opta Optimus
uh something I don't know some like
Minecraft uh commentator a couple
million subscribers but um even
afterwards he like checked up on me
every couple oh that's nice yeah but so
how did this story break because I
thought Taylor Lorenz broke it via the
New York Times but how did you guys
first get in touch
I made a YouTube video oh okay of that
well first I just wanted to be a couple
tweets but then it got on drama alert
and then I was getting all the keemstar
hate so I was like all right I need to
make a YouTube video about it maybe like
explain myself a little bit more and
then um yeah I kind of just the ball
rolled from there she reached out and
then about a year or two later the
Rolling Stones reached out and I was
nervous to do any of those interviews
because I was in the Big Brother uh
casting process so I didn't really do
that but then I was like all right if I
can the more I can explain myself to a
certain extent I think the better off I
am so I decided to do these Publications
yeah and it didn't end up affecting your
casting situation at all oh not at all
and I was I was super happy to hear that
I mean they didn't care whatsoever they
did ask me about it and I was like
understandably so but I I was like is
this going to keep me from being on the
show that we don't give a [ __ ] so it's
like amazing so wait what's the name of
your YouTube channel because I kind of
want to just browse at your original
video
oh hell oh no it's not up anymore I
since deleted that I was getting too
much shakes it was getting like 50 000
views a day and then it was like I think
it was like 99.8 dislike so okay so you
can we were debating if you can beat he
beat our record let's go congrats on
that wait what's the record on our
highlights Channel we were joking that
whenever we make like a video about
Jordan Peterson it's like absolutely
dislike bombed and we have one that's
like 81 dislike so
that is incredible that you almost are
in like a unique situation of receipt of
the receiving end of such incredibly
focused and almost like uh
foreign
transient hate I mean what was that like
for you because were you were you famous
at the time I'm sorry I don't follow
your career or what you do yeah that
sounds good no I had like that's that's
the thing I had I think 7 000
subscribers like 3 000 Instagram
followers and so no one was coming to
show love so I was just like this random
small editor on YouTube that um did like
fortnite videos for um like gaming
channels and whatnot and so the traction
I had was like Zero To None So then when
all this hate came it was like that
that's the whole tsunami there is no
love coming alongside it and that lasted
for probably two years straight so it
was crazy how did that affect you
because I know when I like get mad hate
online sometimes it can feel so [ __ ]
bad and I can only imagine someone who's
never even been in the public eye in
that in that case dealing with something
like that I mean how did that affect you
how did it affect your mental health
oh who's I mean I usually my screen time
was pretty high and if anything if I was
gonna take anything from it then I was
like all right I'm not using my phone
for like three weeks at a time
um because I wouldn't see anything other
than that but
um I mean it was definitely unique to
adjust to because like you said I had
never experienced the public eye or
anything like that so it was kind of a
lot but I was able I I had my amazing
girlfriend who was like helping me along
the way she's also a massive fan of H3
yeah right shout out to um Megan yeah oh
hey Megan
greatest ever oh dude she was only told
me to like sign up for big brother and
all that so she's the best but yeah no
as far as my mental health it was
absolutely insane and keemstar just made
it like a million times more so I don't
want to keep talking about that guy
that's so unusual that's so unless yeah
I never heard anything like that that's
weird I usually he's on the right side
of things and I'm really empathetic so
that's surprising yeah and one thing I
did which I mean if anyone's getting hit
online I recommend not necessarily doing
but I ended up being like playing into
the villain aspect and it was really
tough because I was like all right
everyone hates me anyway why not oh God
my phone is on 10 my bad um but I just
started like playing the villain and
like acting acting even kind of like a
caricature of what they wanted and it
was like the wrong way to go so that I
learned in what way uh were you playing
into the villain what does that mean so
I am let's see oh they call me cloud
chaser I couldn't step away like five
minutes without seeing the words cloud
chaser and uh so I ended up making this
brand called clout Chaser clothing it's
not a thing anymore but then just kind
of like selling into this oh I'm a cloud
chaser thing and it was not the way to
go but I collected the bag via that
brand and so if anything came from it
that was fine
um but no I just started like Joe
falling into the cloud chaser role which
I mean on a business aspect was really
good but on a personal aspect I like
forgot who I was for a couple months it
was it was crazy
um so you actually made money from that
people bought that the cloud chaser [ __ ]
really yeah well I figured if there's
anything that's going to come from this
I need to why it needs to be something
yeah exactly so I I set up the whole
store and the idea was like I would use
designs similar to other YouTubers but
then call it clout Chaser instead I
thought I don't know
wow wow
how much you make from that you
comfortable telling me you don't have to
I'm just curious oh no it was it was
probably like I think I got eight or
nine hundred sales so whatever that was
at the time it was like hoodies and I
probably profited like 20 bucks a hoodie
I don't know it was it was good it was
like what I needed at the time okay yeah
it was it would make it worse
okay
10K let's [ __ ] go more than you made
on Big Brother yeah
it was my third place prize earnings and
now I got it again so in a much more
wholesome way this time all right was
your infamy so much that people were
recognizing you on the streets
oh well I was in college at the time and
everything you know I don't know if you
guys are familiar with Snapchat but if
you swipe to like I forget the right or
the left you see like news stories and
so every single person in my on my
college campus would be like oh are you
the guy from the Snapchat news story and
um but everyone in person thought it was
just cool because I was just in this
random College in Massachusetts
um and so they're like oh yo you're the
guy from Snapchat and I was like that if
you're gonna refer me as anything that's
a lot better than what the online world
is referring to me as so yeah no it was
no hatred at all it was all love oh
that's good yeah online it was a whole
different actually a b is empathizing
with you you made a clout Goblin sure
baby I didn't know yeah I was so annoyed
of everyone I was so annoyed if everyone
call me Cloud Goblin so I made this
shirt I was like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
own it wait wait exactly yes that is
that's so funny wait was this when you
were already with on the show yeah oh
that was probably that was probably my
fault bro I'm sorry about starting that
but did you make some money from that
cloud goblin shirt oh no I just just for
myself I was just like yeah because you
play into it it a little yeah I was
playing into it yeah but it is a little
bit annoying to be doing stuff in social
media then every time you post something
everyone's like oh there's a cloud
Goblin again it's like why the [ __ ] what
do you think I'm doing yeah yeah it's
the it's the impulse of wanting to rise
above or yeah I'll show you're
unbothered right and but it's tough and
and um
av's not a cloud Goblin he's one of the
greatest employees you could ever wish
for oh thank you oh dude I'm a huge
Starkiller fan yeah oh thank you buddy
yes I got you bro
um so
to the uh by the way is your if your
phone's dying do you want to switch
phones or plug your thing in oh
um my girlfriend got me a charger hell
yeah hell yeah okay cool
so to the charges basically so how did
it happen you made a tweet what what
motivated you to make the tweet
um it was just like
I don't even know at a certain point I
saw like just imagine someone who you
had the opposite experience of the
online world and I was like all right I
feel like I'm festering up all of this
and I think about it every day I might
as well just get it off of my shoulders
if anything I was like holding this way
and I wanted to just let it go so you
had some resentment towards Jimmy and
his crew seeing him become so successful
and you're like man those guys are such
dicks to me well not the crew actually
the crew was some of the nicest group of
people I've ever met like I love
everybody on the crew nothing against
any of them
um I some of them I still keep in
contact with uh so and like I went to I
remember I went to Chris's wedding like
everyone on the crew I love and I again
now know hold hold numbers that meant to
Jimmy himself whatsoever I'm like so far
removed from that scene like it almost
seems like a different person like me at
18 talking about this than now but uh
yeah did Jimmy ever
um reach out to or anything like that
you gave me a phone call but I was in um
I was in class and so then I called him
after and then I it we didn't end up
blinking because then he was busy but it
just the timing didn't work out for a
phone call but
um yeah
I think I find that kind of sweet that
he called you even though you guys never
connected yeah no it was actually nice
and I I didn't actually think that would
happen so the fact that he did want to
talk and I was like dude I'm in that
three-hour class right now I can't leave
and I'm not in college anymore but again
years ago so I was like all right if
anything I know he wanted to talk about
it and that is all that I do that is
very interesting actually well
and also what's interesting is that you
made some tweets like did they even get
a lot of likes or did the story just
blow up from keemstar
I think it got like 800 likes a pop
that's so interesting nobody would have
ever cared about it nobody would ever
talked about it Taylor would have never
probably wrote an article about it
unless keemstar took this little thing
and turned it into some [ __ ] [ __ ]
headline to defend Mr Beast right he
goes he goes look at the horrible thing
this guy's saying about Mr Beast I don't
believe it though it's like well you're
the one projecting it
dude it was crazy because I was like
then I I the tweets ended up getting
deleted because I was like this I didn't
want to open up the floodgates for a
hate I just wanted to say a story and
maybe I don't know if you could or
couldn't turn off tweet replies that's
probably what I should have done uh if
that's even possible but yeah no it blew
up right after that and I was like okay
I didn't want any of this but at a
certain point maybe I should have
understood like there are news outlets
for YouTubers and that's probably going
to get picked up but ideally it wouldn't
have but it did and I I totally
understand why but um I never chat like
keemstar I never really talked with me
or anything like me and keemstar never
hopped on the phone so that would have
been nice I guess
so here here's the I guess the
accusations that uh
you posted about Mr Donaldson I didn't
know that was his name that's Jimmy's
last name yeah Miss uh Mr Donaldson had
berated him almost every day
Mr Donaldson often called him by a
phrase used to insult people with mental
disabilities I'm assuming you mean like
restarted thank you Dan yeah is that the
one you're talking about
can you say it again
uh restarted yeah oh let's get restarted
let's get restarted in here yes exactly
let's let's get restarted in here let's
go
okay and Mr Turner said leaving him in
tears wow he made you cry from yeah dude
I'm I'm a sensitive boy
that's a lot uh so so at what point
would he berate you if he saw an edit
and he's like no not like that oh it was
only it was only once or twice where
like
um I don't know there was an edit that
had a deadline and I did it but then I
was like oh no we need it again and then
we need it again and it would have it
was chaotic and a mess and truly I hope
if there is anyone watching and I know
the fupa Troopers would never uh please
don't send hate I am all good I have
received love for the past week online
so I I do not want it to drink Nobody's
Gonna Hate You from fupa Trooper Army
trust me yes dude it's all up from the
troops back here hell yeah and I I don't
think there's any further story for
keemstar to squeeze out of this so Oh
you mean to send it to Mr Beast you mean
don't send it
oh no don't send oh I meant myself but
maybe also definitely not Mr Beast I
mean that would be like .001 percentage
of his engagement and like yeah nobody
would see it nobody will see it yeah
yeah all right
so um
so what is it that he perceived you did
wrong when he started calling you
restarted
um there was this video where he wanted
me to take all the clips add them
together and then hit a certain number
of kind of like a montage to like show
him reaching some goal I forget the
exact goal but and um I don't know I
like the numbers weren't hitting because
there's like click bait numbers and
there's real numbers so I couldn't show
all these transactions when Idol was
describing one thing and the video
showing another thing and so it was
quite literally impossible to hit
um and then I remember what ended up
happening after like a week of this
argument was he because it was true
everything I was doing it wasn't gonna
hit this number I hope this was making
sense also so yeah I gotcha I got you so
at the end he like popped in at the end
of the video he popped in with like a
vlog and he was like oh also I gave some
money to my sister or something I don't
know so it didn't ever hit the number
even when I didn't do the final edit
um so I was right all along yeah so what
he came in and yelled at you
yeah yeah well I think it escalated
because I was like yo I'm gonna what
take a walk because I've been at like a
desk for 40 hours this week trying to
edit this Impossible Video so then I go
to my co-worker I start complaining I'm
like dude I don't know what the hell to
do then he sees me complaining to
another co-worker
um and then starts getting pissed and
maybe understand what we saw I was
talking [ __ ] about my boss in the same
office so like maybe read it but it was
it got very heated
it seems like you know in the very
beginnings of a YouTube channel like
that when it's just 10 people and you're
all like relatively close
that sometimes someone like Jimmy it's
easy to forget the boss employee Dynamic
you know what I mean oh yeah totally and
with that in mind like no he was I think
20 at the time no 20 year old is set up
to have this like multi-million dollar
business within the course of a year
because it exploded when I when I first
got there so like I can never be like oh
how are you not the perfect boss right
because no one set up to be this like
Tycoon out of YouTube at such a young
age how would he have known so I I
totally understand all of it so were you
crying in front of him or did you like
walk away and cry no I I had I had a
tearful moment after I walked away
because I was like there's just so much
going on this is so chaotic and I moved
here from Massachusetts so like North
Carolina what am I I don't have anything
to do right now I just like I don't I
don't know anyone here I'm freaking in
North Carolina for a month deep so yeah
I was like well here we go I guess I
have to deal with this and uh it says Mr
Turner who did not grow up with Mr
Donaldson said that while his boss
regular featured his hometown friends
and videos he he had struggled to get
acknowledgment
yeah that was true and that is something
else I understand because I was like a
cameraman and editor but then there was
like different like on-screen people and
off-screen people and so I think
throughout the Growing Pains of going
from 18 to 23 which I am now
um I I kind of get that and I was I
wouldn't say relatively new to editing
but relatively new to being a cameraman
slash editor and there were a few times
where like I don't I don't know I that
was one thing that now being older like
why would I have gone on screen
acknowledgment I totally understand that
right I see yeah I understand but I
guess there was some friction about
because the guys who were on screen
ended up all becoming like pretty big in
their own right just for being in the
video so I can see that there would be
friction between people off screen and
people on screen or you're saying well
why can't I be on there why are they all
getting and also were they were the ones
that was were winning massive like
amounts of money right because they were
participating in his videos was that
happening too yeah yeah and it was also
like like at the time the people in the
videos it'd be like me and like five
other people so I wasn't a a big crew
and then sometimes like I would be on
camera give a good joke and then it was
like either it might have been like I
mean not to say I'm a funny guy but it
might have been too good so then it's
like all right cut that and give it to
someone else and I'd be like what the
hell were you saying he caught you
because it was too good
well listen dude I don't want to say
that but sometimes if I was an
off-screen personality who said
something the line would then get fed to
someone else oh you they would reshoot
it you say or you have a hunch that they
would take the comment that was funny
and reshoot it I know it would happen
to this person that's kind of oh oh they
would do it right in front of you yeah
they would say wait that was funny
reshoot it with someone else yes it was
like sick that's kind of crazy yeah so
who would they give the line to
um I have no idea maybe Chris or
something probably
whoa what do you think his motivation
for that was
or just like building up the
personalities probably that were already
there and it's like I I think he did
want to build up his friends socials and
whatever so like you know and if the
pillars of that channel are a couple
personalities and then like there's the
cameraman chiming in it's like all right
well let's keep it ah that is very
interesting and very strategic I guess
although I gave me like coming for like
after seeing watching your Arc of
watching different YouTubers like you
kind of gave me David dobrik Vibes you
know let's shoot the laughing again you
know
very strategic but I guess from Hit yeah
that is real interesting to know it's so
interesting to learn about all the kind
of behind the scenes that goes on there
um the other one is you saying that uh
you are not credited for anything you
did you would ask for credit and he
would credit someone else yeah I do
remember one time I asked for credit and
then he credited another editor and I
was like what the hell is this so we did
it on purpose or just like because he
was so special I think he probably he
was probably pretty spaced out I I have
I I can't imagine I don't like looking
back on this how long ago I don't think
he was malicious in any way I just don't
think he was a great boss at 20. so yeah
with I don't think if I was in his
position I probably would have been a
pretty bad boss at that age too yeah
that's very interesting
um
that's just so crazy that that uh that
was you man well I really appreciated
talking to you about that
um Mr Beast if you're out there do you
want to talk to him would you be happy
if he called you just to sit just to
Bear the hatchet or no oh yeah that
would be dope I mean I'm sure he has
like a million things going on so
understandably so but if we had a five
minute phone call I would just be like
dude
um I mean we're on two opposite sides
like I'm not in the YouTube editing game
I make YouTube videos but like I'm just
me making rugs and [ __ ] so yeah like if
you if we ended up on a call I'd be like
bro I hope you're doing well and that's
probably all I would say I I hold I
don't I don't ever think about this
anymore and obviously especially because
I've been busy the past few months
definitely not it was a nice break from
my phone I didn't see any of this but um
yeah no it was it was dope and
simultaneously I well one I would love
to chat with him but two uh just thank
you so much for having me on the podcast
again I'm a massive fan and have been
for years
um and so dude this means the world yes
thank you it's very nice did you see
anything else back because like they
painted it in this story it seems like
your your accusations are mildly tame
basically you know a couple of young
guys they felt like he was a dick he
didn't credit you and stuff and I
totally get that that's like a pretty
toxic work environment but the way I
guess that Taylor spun it was like that
she tried to turn this whole
I forget what was the title but it was
like YouTube giant uh toxic workplace
she spun it into something I don't
remember what but what was your reaction
to that article when it came out did you
think it was a fair representation or
did you feel like uh she did too much
with it I don't and I I don't actually
have an opinion I don't remember the
article I dude I'm gonna oh are you are
you asking me yeah yeah I'm asking you
oh yeah all right
um no I honestly I wish I like I wish I
remembered what the article was like I I
just know I know the article exists and
I did read it at the time but since I
have quite literally no idea but I would
say Taylor or Lorenz is one of the
nicest reporters I've ever spoken to so
she is nice
yeah she is she is really nice actually
I've spoken to her a few times
well there it is uh Turner third place
Big Brother
what's next for you is there are you in
like the big brother Universe now is
there like big brother Superstar shows
like what happens now yeah dude I can't
get away from the Big Brother cast bro
they just yo I heard one of you guys
voted him off which one of you which one
of you piece of shits evicted him oh
dude what the hell I'm getting a phone
call how do I
um I'll send a voicemail all right sorry
you can take it it's fun we did that
last week with Seaman it was it was
Monty he's the one but it's okay we love
him what place did Monty get this guy
was out at first so this guy sucks at
Big Brother uh at first yo that house is
baller where are you guys right now
um we are I don't dude I don't even know
La uh Sherman Oaks okay player damn and
what place did what place did the guy
who voted you off get
um what play Oh second
[ __ ] brat
dude that's what I'm saying was it worth
it bro
the funniest part if he listen peace and
love if he took me he would have won so
he blundered himself I don't even damn
you blew it
peace and love all right this was a fun
super interesting chat I appreciate that
Turner I wish you all the luck in the
future by the way you're doing rug swag
where can people check out your your uh
content oh hell yeah dude so I'm on
Instagram and my name is uh Turner so
just
t-u-r-n-u-r-r or I have a store it's a
thrift store an art store in Bridgewater
Massachusetts called the rug Shack and
you can find that rug Shack underscore
on Instagram
um I'm also I I am yet to be verified on
Twitter so if anyone from Twitter is
watching do that but yeah then just
t-u-r-n-u-r on Instagram on Twitter but
thank you very much dude very cool the
rug Shack baby let's go rug Shack baby
hey he follows me I'm gonna follow you
back oh you just gotta follow from Dan
there you go that's good I'm literally a
huge fan of every single person
individually um if Ian is there Ian I
love you too I haven't seen your face I
know you are
a lot thank you I followed you yesterday
too thank you dude I saw dude literally
when I saw a 908e and I was like Megan
oh my God Ian followed me yeah that Ian
follows pretty exclusive I don't even
think Ian was following me until
recently because I called him out on it
on your on your Incognito uh you have a
secret
well dude also
stream Zach Lewis's music dude because
oh yeah Troubadour on the 13th yeah
you're gonna be there on the Troubadour
on the 13th oh dude you know what I
don't know I might be back in
Massachusetts but if I'm here I will 100
go well let me know and I'll give you
some tickets
oh dude thank you oh hell yeah then I
might have to
Turner I was in the bathroom earlier did
you say that we grew up in the same
neighborhood
oh not neighborhood but we're both from
Massachusetts we actually spoke on NC I
mean I was just a random person but like
a year ago I think I called into the
show
um I didn't make it all the way through
but we talked and then I was put in the
queue and so then we talked like five
minutes about Massachusetts oh [ __ ] okay
yeah you know what I always when I call
screen I always took priority in
Massachusetts numbers
yep okay I actually do remember that now
okay I see how it is back there
Massachusetts
well I'm glad we have mass
representation on the uh on on H3 by the
way this one piece rug is thick
oh hell yeah dude oh you're showing my
[ __ ] dude that means so much all right
have you watched are you've totally
caught up on one piece or no
um no I I need to prioritize getting
caught up on Jujutsu because that's my
favorite anime by far but then I will
I'll watch it well one piece is the one
with like a million episodes right
that's great yeah it's got like 1060
apps
are you um are you I'm on number 400 I'm
working my way damn oh dude I'm on
number like 30. so I'm gonna get there
but yeah yeah way back there man you
ever watched a Jujutsu bro I've seen it
all it's great but there's only one
season of it right well I I'm on episode
I think like 15 so I'm still cut I'm
like awesome yeah that show's really
cool
hell yeah dude well all right
um also also I will say if um this is
like a dream of mine so I have to say it
while I'm here if uh Teddy fresh ever
needs custom tufted rugs for a line I've
added you know who to hit up I love
those rugs I think we could work
something out because those rugs are so
sick or we'll just buy one from you I
don't know that would also be dope I
would just send one because
I always been looking for a rug Master
to make a life-size replica of the Howie
Mandel prolapse Tick Tock oh wait dude I
don't know
we have someone working on that one oh
we do already okay all right does Turner
even know about that Meme he might have
been locked away oh you may have been
locked the weight or yeah you might not
be aware [ __ ] wait did you you don't
know about Howie Mandel showing a
prolapse on Tick Tock
dude you missed some good memes bro dude
that's what I'm saying like I like 80
episodes to catch up on which is good
because usually there's a lack of H3
content and I'm like dude I gotta keep
up but you are less late for the show
than you used to be maybe that's true or
not I don't know that's true or not got
him you got bad info
dude I might have that's that's Miss
info if I've ever heard it but um just
when we're done here Google Howie Mandel
prolapse and uh you're gonna like that
sounds like the most cursed thing ever
but I will look it up just for you good
it's good all right Turner thank you man
appreciate talking to you thank you
congrats on that third place thanks man
there's curses to your friend there who
uh betrayed you curses Judas
thank you again all right so take care
bud nice talking to you God bless
there it is Turner third place big
brother third cool nice guy trooper and
Mr BEAST's whistleblower
yeah that's kind of crazy what happened
with the whole Mr Beast Arc because like
he just [ __ ] posted on Twitter or
something and then
yeah turned into this whole big thing
and who would have thought keemstar was
the reason for that who
would imagine
uh the pope gave us a a big old Dono
knife don't New Zealand finally in a
financial position where I can support
y'all
oh thank you man
thank you always been there oh thank you
for always being there Ethan I helped a
lot of people through dark times thank
you brother
rattle your dags that's [ __ ]
he says is it one now well now
means family and Maori is that the
Aboriginal language well that's dumb
yeah
morale one out
did I love New Zealand just because they
say rattle your dags which is my
favorite I say that to my boys I say
that to everybody my fave
all right well we have a lot of great
stuff still uh that was a phone call uh
we gotta talk about the the try guys the
try guys yeah maybe we should just get
into that
should we do our oh you know there's
another thing maybe we should do first
we have as you guys know a fan favorite
is uh Pride minute
but I don't know if that's working for
us it seems to be alienating us because
we're losing our men every [ __ ] day
men are unsubscribing and droves you're
blaming that on Pride minute
yes yes I think they are running
extremely homophobic and says our Jordan
Peterson says trans people are an
Abomination man
so I've thought well you know what
and actually got lots of posts on the
server being like yo I'm a [ __ ] man
and I watch this show and so you know
like shout out to our wasps like look at
this post so we got to represent them
protect yourself a thousand uh likes he
says yo I'm a republican I'm male I'm
white and I'm a huge fan
what's up dude top comment anyone here
from Arizona those are not my people but
you are
you're the only person in order to hear
from Arizona what the heck and dog
what the hecking dog yeah um white males
rise up someone said not in that context
I mean uh delete me from this
conversation
yeah so
um
let's just do I was thinking let's do
manly minute hmm
oh is it started I don't have the timer
so this is it bars we're coming on out
here
[Music]
all right I just started it minutes
God loves America
God is on America's side
muscles
bald eagles and killing Arabs
now I don't know about you but nothing
against me rock hard like blowing up a
mall in Iraq that's right
[Music]
what else do I love Budweiser
and [ __ ] going to church
yes
sometimes when I drink too much
Budweiser I slap my wife
but he had it coming and I say damn it
woman why'd you make me do that how do
you feel about titties hey I love him
did it oh I love me oh boy I love me
some big white titties
all right that's a minute let's uh stop
it stop the music all right everyone men
back in the [ __ ] closet back under
the thumb of the minorities you [ __ ]
you you just got emasculated by me [ __ ]
basically just going to cut off your
dick and put it in a lock box
what are you married you're whipped your
[ __ ] whipped [ __ ]
you probably drink non-alcoholic beer
what is that [ __ ] called
[ __ ] you said it you took out duels
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
yeah dick rider you're a dick sucker hop
up my [ __ ] dick
back in the under the thumb guys time to
emasculate yourselves that's right oh
come on guys don't do tomatoes during
manly hour we have to be we have to be
respectful we're trying to get them in
back in this community not drive them
away
where would we be without men all these
people all these women in chat
they don't give men any respect
they think just because they go and get
jobs no that they don't have to take
care of their man
LMFAO I don't [ __ ] care that you
worked 40 hours this week I want a
sandwich
and a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you buckle Duty
uh
tired of pretending you don't have to
interview Harry Mack who's that love
from Yemen shout out Yemen who's Harry
Mack
don't know okay he's a musical artist
and he's an artist and rapper
best known for his unique jaw-dropping
visual freestyling rap he wrote I just I
just noticed this is from Harry Mack
official so it's not necessarily just
described yourself as jaw dropping bro
my podcast is jaw dropping
yeah that that manly minute was intense
I lost my wedding ring I can't find it
that's because when you go out when real
men go out to the bar they take their
wedding ring off that's right you really
lost it I did somewhere I wonder where
is it anyways yeah I don't wear it what
happened it flung off your hand and I
was I was playing I threw it off yeah
you can't tie down a good Moon yeah
so we'll work on that yeah we'll work oh
man but okay God I gotta pee again this
[ __ ] gamer sup just runs right
through you
but I get so energized
this black cherry flavor I'm not kidding
is insanely good
so good
all right I gotta go pee so
um when we come back we'll finally get
to the try guy Fiasco which is so funny
and I'm sorry I mean that with peace and
love I know a family's been torn apart
and everything but like it's so [ __ ]
good
you know if you ignore all that which we
will of course
[Music]
oh yeah yes we will
uh
hell yeah being a man uh hell yeah being
a man loves some [ __ ] hell yeah Roberto
yeah yeah that's what's up Roberto that
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] [ __ ] too and Obama
agrees
W men
oh right I see that's clever
that's clever Caroline
uh what else we got here I see some
people in the chat asking why Abby
doesn't wear his ring
[Music]
you care to elaborate
busted
yeah fake
and it makes my finger itch
it's okay be aware enough rings for
everybody yeah you can yeah cam will
wear it for me I don't like wearing
rings I like wearing jewelry in general
I love it
um but it also doesn't fit me my finger
got fatter since I started now working
out and it's very hard to get off
you better get back on that boy but I
found it back on that treadmill boy yeah
yeah
so how you guys doing
good I'm trying to
to the right part of the Super Chat
spreadsheet okay here we go
oh everybody was just donating during
the Turner interview saying showing the
Howie thing I missed that well I'm glad
we caught it at the very end there yeah
it
was my new favorite sound bite
just wanted to share quoting Jeff Dunham
got me suspended in the fourth grade
that's what you get
uh what's everyone's favorite gamer sup
supp flavor I mean they sent us like 50.
I've only tried
four or five of them so far like the the
raspberry one I like the gamer part
9000. wait you tried that one yeah yeah
that's really good the guacamole gamer
fart 9000. does it taste like guacamole
it just tastes good I can't describe it
but it is it's good
I know it tastes like beef Cherry a
little skeptical
y'all should have Dorian Electra on uh I
just oh I love that you know you're
familiar oh yeah I'm a big hyper pop
head okay hyper POP heads rise up
um I would love 100 gecks to come on the
show I filmed them on fish Center once
and I just love hundred gags I know you
are a fan good geckhead big geckhead any
geckheads out in the chat I'm sure
they're out there like big fans of Geico
uh yeah exactly okay yeah big fans of
saving 15 or more on your car insurance
shout out government any fans of that
therapy Gekko a friend of the show is
actually blowing up lately eh yeah yeah
he's uh doing great he's going on tour
and everything I talked to see it I miss
him he had Bobby Lee on his damn show
that was awesome he had Jeff he had uh a
lot of folks he gets he gets the guess
what it was on that show yeah yeah
gecked up gecked up that's right it's
kind of cool that he did that okay Ethan
I'm being nice Chef for one stop
foreign
actually Jeff's a good guy I'm going on
this barbershop show in a couple weeks
right you can't come fast enough though
although we were saying he's going to
give me a mole or some dumb [ __ ]
there's no way I'm Gonna Keep whatever
haircut he gives me
that's [ __ ] up that's not BFF Behavior
because I'm not the kind of guy that
gets like haircuts it makes me
uncomfortable you know can you tell him
when you see him he said he was going to
send me and Zach some hair product we
never got it yeah if you can collect on
that like Pomade or some [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] like a brand he likes or like he is
his brand he makes hair products yeah
hmm wow didn't send you guys huh you
made us an office
okay you guys want to talk about the
trade the try guys cheating yeah let's
do that now what I first of all I'm not
like the try guy expert okay I'm not
super familiar with try guy lore
or any of us
any try guy fans in the house no I'm
gonna try hard but right right right
well I know that there were like
probably the biggest act on BuzzFeed for
a while
they're like the kings of soy face
undoubtedly I mean I've only learned
this over the last few days but I mean
if you just go to their Channel and look
through there there's this one guy in
particular
um the guitar guy with the glasses he's
got like the soiest face I've ever seen
and it's not that I dislike them but
man that soy face is pit it's just so
[ __ ] annoying
this guy this [ __ ] guy and I you know
you guys might be fans of his and he
might be the nicest guy in the world I
don't know
but this man has undefeated soy face
and uh let me just go back here I'm
trying to find some really good swipe
face looks like they Diversified a
little bit
um I mean I'm seeing them they're all
over the Applebee's one but there's like
really really good ones and his mouth
opens like crazy wide that's like yeah
that that Carl Junior one it's pretty
intense
yeah apparent their whole shtick is that
they try stuff right
and on BuzzFeed the videos were they
they got like really good headlines you
know um
here this is this is kind of like
classic soy
it's Chili's bro it's just ribs dude
it's just [ __ ] ribs bro
you know what I'm saying it's just ribs
bro have you not eaten in in in
30 days what's that face those are
chilies baby back ribs it's chilies
kind of them ribs
[Music]
yeah you see so this guy is the king of
soy soy face oh here's a good one and
[ __ ] too this is the Apparently his
name is Keith and he has a lot of fans
in our chat everybody good we love him
we love we we love wheat people saying
stop and you gotta you cannot
guys you guys gotta admit he's the king
of soy face okay
I mean love him or hate him
that's not a l take that's literally
factual information that I'm presenting
to you Keith is the king of soy face but
we love him right okay if you guys love
him then good
again it's not personal I don't know
anything about the guy
you know your face man
but on BuzzFeed they had really
interesting like titles where they're
like trying like uh a one dollar Ramen
uh 20 Ramen and a 500 Ramen and they
would like compare it right that was
their whole stick
and one of the members
uh his name is
Ned Fulmer this guy actually right here
here actually here he is with his wife
he was like known as the wife guy he was
apparently like obsessed with his wife
why are you worried about my wife people
would joke about him like uh
they'd be like how long can Ned go
without mentioning his wife
and these guys are drama free yeah these
guys are like clean as it gets I mean
this is Buzzfeed
apologies to to uh uh what's the soy
face guy's name
he apologies to Keith I'm on my hands
and he's begging please forgive me
I don't want to take on Keith Army
here is hearing about the try guys drama
where Ned cheated on his wife is
absolutely insane to me considering they
literally hosted an ethics of healthy
relationships panel at my University bro
who would even have the balls to host
that that of course you're cheating
ethics
of a healthy relationship like
dude
wow
the ironies like
and it's unbelievable it's overwhelming
um
oh Keith Army's pissed at me [ __ ]
Keith army with Keith I want to
apologize to Soy Keith
he's a super nice guy he's just got a
soy face and that's just something I
that's just something that affects me
when I see their thumbnails
yes I do soy face it's for a joke we do
it ironically which is different than
doing it seriously get the fact straight
[Music]
Keith would never cheat on his wife
though he's a good guy I don't know if
he's married or not yeah I know they're
not part of BuzzFeed they left and did
their own thing I'm getting to that
um
but if you go to someone who's doing an
ethics on healthy relationship they
probably are like they're both cheating
usually yeah thank you boss dude I we
did I said don't use this one and I
didn't yeah but
but that's a straight look at that silly
face man well that isn't that's this is
the guy who cheated yeah I know yeah no
and and that's a powerful powerful one
as well yeah I mean what is the ethics
of healthy relationships don't cheat
that's like it
that's like probably like the first
bullet point yeah don't cheat there's
there's more to it than that but yeah
it's a good start
yeah
so um
let's see here
's the try guys yeah
so let's go back Ned's whole Persona as
I said
was the wife guy here's a bunch of this
guy we talked about already
um it would upload wholesome family
content is this content still up now
I was as of yesterday let me check again
I don't know if they're scrub every time
Ned Fulmer says my wife like they turned
it into a meme
I would like to watch that
Ned and Ariel being absolutely perfect
yo they're so overcompensating any
couple that presents themselves as
perfect
is in shambles behind the scenes I
guarantee it you know look at the
Shaytards or whatever the [ __ ] they're
called their name was
shark Shay Carl was like you remember
him they had like the perfect family and
that dude was like a monster behind the
scenes just like a raging alcoholic that
was flirting with all these girls
let's see
[Music]
here it is guys Ned's saying my wife my
wife guys
[Music]
it's a minute long video okay enough
Preamble my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife that's my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife that is
a staggering amount of times in my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife
I'm married to my wife my wife my wife
[Music]
to sound like Professor Snape
that was uh
that was actually a staggering amount of
my wife that was a lot impressive that
was a lot and um that must have taken
forever to edit holy [ __ ]
but you know what I'm saying like don't
ever trust these people who are
presenting to you this perfect
relationship because it's not what's
going on I promise they're gonna get
divorced
one of them's already [ __ ] someone
else guaranteed every time
the really sad part is they have two
kids
cheating is so despicable man
especially when there's kids involved
[ __ ] bro was it worth it just get some
strange ass and if you're in love with
her just get a divorce you know if it's
that important
well I don't think we've even gone into
it yet but it's it's even worse than
that because the person he cheated on
his wife with it was an employee yeah
that's even bad that's like ethically
double wait double whammy how does that
fit into the ethics of uh healthy
relationship
they did that like a year ago so I'm
just curious when they included the [ __ ]
your producers yeah
wow what a piece of [ __ ] dude
who would do that
ah
so moving on that was very interesting
uh
one user found a clip that aged like
milk
here is our boy Ned
oh here's his wife who by all counts
seems like a great gal
and a good mom and a good wife
[Laughter]
wow how long ago was this
uh there was no context on the
whoa oh this is 150 000 likes so yeah
wow
beautiful too you know
again I just hate men who have kids they
[ __ ] put their wife through
childbirth
they deliver you two beautiful children
and then you go and cheat on them bro
[ __ ] that that is so sad it's so [ __ ]
up yeah and she probably believed in
this like image of theirs of the perfect
couple
um and that they're happy and
everything's okay and then now the whole
world is just like
her world is collapsing and she has to
deal with it in the public eye too that
is really to add on to what she said
that is the most [ __ ] up is when one
person's relationship doesn't know the
extent that the other person is [ __ ]
up I mean because sometimes I feel like
maybe Austin is McBroom is a good
example and his wife may kind of be in
on some things together
but like even in my hometown I've seen
it before where like a really religious
girl is like really loyal to a guy who
she thinks is religious who's secretly
like drinking on the side and doing a
bunch of [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that so
they're just a different person yeah
they don't know exactly yeah right right
ethics on a healthy relationship I can't
get over that it's pretty well post that
like in all the world who has hosted
such a pretentious panel
my goodness
overcompensating a little bit so
um yeah and I mean the aspect of having
the kids is for me
a dad of two boys
and putting your kids through that I
mean that's lifelong trauma for your
kids at that young age too where the
where the parents of the relationship
has such a big impact on them
and it's got to be humiliating for his
wife too and she's got to do this in the
public eye
because he had to go host a ethics
in a healthy relationship panel
and make it super ironic
so moving on
uh
date night cookbook
this is their book oh [ __ ] me they wrote
a they wrote a wife and husband cookbook
Ned and Ariel Fulmer from the try guys
it's date night
do you know where your husband is
it's 8 P.M on a Saturday night do you
know where your husband is let's read
the intro dating is tough
marriage is even tougher
apparently
in today's fast-paced world of Tinder
and takeout but we're about to tell you
may sound outrageous but it's true
there's no better way to get to know
person you're dating than through a
home-cooked meal seriously
whether you're serving up a sensational
sage and butter roast chicken or a cozy
spaghetti and meatball
that's why everybody should go to
hellofresh.com
65h3tv that's right
can I can I just clarify real quick when
I'm saying the guy drinking on the side
I'm not talking about just drinking in a
normal relationship I'm talking about uh
extremely religious secret secret yeah
when the girl is covered she's wearing a
scarf because she believes so much in
religion and secretly the dude is
drinking on the side that's what I mean
peace and love it's a huge betrayal of
trust yeah
because if you're willing to do that
that's like a big thing then you're
willing to go you're probably willing to
[ __ ] someone yeah
um that's certainly been our experience
which is exactly why we compiled a
cookbook of our favorite man apparently
this recipes didn't hit right because he
[ __ ] someone
do you know what I mean like those
recipes don't hit that hard if they did
he would have never cheated
don't buy this book because you will get
a divorce
I'm just saying it but I'm just saying
didn't work out
um
here's a good one for him uh
actually you know this could be a good
uh starting point for Ned divorce dad's
cooking Survival Guide
maybe time for a new uh cookbook Ned you
know just something to work on uh poor
John Williams John Williams go through
the face of that [ __ ] oh you really
wrote this book John and you put your
kid in it
okay divorce dad's cooking survival God
I'm sorry but if I saw this on the shelf
and like Barnes Noble
and even if I desperately needed the
help do you know how humiliating it is
to buy this let's try to check out yeah
I'd go to Amazon and order online but
even the discrete shipping I mean why
just call it pathetic loser divorce
piece of [ __ ] dad I don't know how to
cook for his kid can you imagine walking
man
it's 101 pages so he's got a lot to say
it has uh it's just sad let's see the
reviews I got a joke gift like that one
year for my birthday from a buddy that
was like let me see if I can find it it
was like microwave cooking for one oh
yeah the name of the book
that's a good one man
a skill we should I mean put it in and
put Power
I remember it was actually really funny
yeah she's a legend
yeah I mean that's literally the
loneliest status
it reminds me of that old H3 video you
made about that dude that cooked I think
it was like what's up I remember he
would just go what's up Tomcats I don't
remember yeah and it was just the most
sad depressing oh God right yeah it was
Mike it was like uh nacho cheese and
stuff yeah or nachos by the way I wanted
to eat those nachos he made those slugs
like they slapped
it was like on a public access show yeah
College something yeah so um let's see
here's another
dating a married guy here's another one
the irony is not lost
wait wait dating a married guy wait what
is this who's Megan Reich it's like
somebody else's podcast that he came on
as a guest for and that was just a
little click bait yeah but I mean now
he's down obviously actually he's up for
it he sure was something was up oh it's
her this is the girl who
this podcast it is right
banger Banger tweet
you got him good girl
love that for you
so this is how it all went down
um oh here actually Ned is sorry we got
an exclusive Ned is actually working on
this as we speak
um
[Music]
so if you guys want to support Ned you
can go ahead and uh yeah it's gonna be
tough for him he lost his job unless his
relationship divorce dad's cooking a
survival guide ladies and gentlemen
yeah so how this all went down is that
viewers noticed that
the group member Ned Fulmer was absent
from the last three try Guy videos
and podcast episodes
but he was still present in their group
photos and promotional material which
is kind of weird
but these people are super sluice when I
first heard this Theory I was like it's
probably that he like something happened
but somehow they figured out he was
cheating before he even said anything
uh fans noticed Fulmer's wife Arielle
was missing from the last two episodes
of you can sit with us a podcast helmed
by the try guys wives oh
they even have a wife Circle
dude how could you [ __ ] this up I know
like when you decided to [ __ ] this girl
to put it vulgarly
you had to know that this was going to
ruin your whole [ __ ] life dude I must
say that I've had some post-coital
regrets of course the post-quartile
regret for this one it's gonna be off
the charts
foreign
from the guys wives podcast the try guys
have also reduced the amount of content
they're currently producing to one video
a week
they make more than that yeah I believe
they were making four
who would do that that's insane four
videos a week
it's crazy
I love to be a psycho to do that
yep
um
uh now the internet detectives have
connected the dots to screenshots of
text provided by a Reddit user
who claims they saw Fulmer cheating on
his wife with one of the try guys
producers
and also star of want of I don't know if
it's their show a different show called
food babies I'm not going to say her
name because I don't want to necessarily
think she needs to get mobbed
so there's a Twitter thread that kind of
explains it a lot cleaner than the
Reddit thread
um
right oh but this is where the story
broke yeah
this is insane dude
so somebody saw him in a club making out
with one of his employees do you know
how [ __ ] unethical that is
I mean you were proposing
mud wrestling with AB earlier this not
kissing as part of the it's I mean you
know I got accepted a few would slip in
there
bro stop it's not the same
um
so the picture actually was kind of here
let me go to the Twitter thread it's got
all the pictures and stuff yeah yeah
okay the pictures are like super grainy
too and just a side note the girl who he
was cheating with had a fiance right I
forgot well I don't want to say her name
anyway because it's not really yeah no
one knows her but she also cheated on
her fiance with him
because if you don't want to say her
name that's fine but that's not really
the case either she she's a prominent
person on their Channel and an internet
personality herself has she put out a
statement or anything nope as of last
night when we were looking everything
over it's possible she did today check
again
I just can't get over these people doing
such dumb [ __ ] and ruining their lives
both of them man
I mean she's been part of their life so
she knew the situation that he was
married he had kids and stuff so I mean
and she had a fiance man
L that is Juicy knock it over my wife
all right so here we go we got the whole
thing here
so this all started when fans began to
notice that net uh that uh
he was missing
which makes me think that obviously this
had been going on behind the scenes for
a minute
they were trying to Hush Hush it
Keith soy Keith my man
nicest guy on the internet
the soiest man and also the nicest
you gotta appreciate that like meanwhile
while his one of his best friends and
co-workers has like their companies in
turmoil everything's going to [ __ ] this
is that soy ass face boy we and we out
in Vegas eating buffets and [ __ ]
well that's where it happened
really it was during that this trip yeah
I mean that's the club with their where
they hooked up or whatever was in Vegas
that is epic
but we love Keith Keith eats everything
and Ned was eating everything too you
know yeah get something off man you know
secret menu
I'm not seeing this statement from her
uh so he was missing typically the guys
have an intro for their videos where all
four guys appear but in recent videos
this has been replaced yo they cut his
ass out
only Eugene Zach and Keith appear in the
new tracksuit ad despite Ned attending
the photo shoot
bro they just cut his ass out expecting
no one to notice
it's like that famous picture of Stalin
where the dude disappears next to him
wait is anyone actually a try guy fan
because I'm curious about that
apparently half of their chat is and he
was a hero who I can talk to about it
because I'm curious about the dynamic
between them
I used to watch it when I was BuzzFeed
way back actually is this a workplace
how does this work in the ethics of
everyone's saying it was in New York
that they cheated not in uh Vegas so
apologies yeah I mean is this ethical or
I just want to say he's not a co-worker
he doesn't work here
that's fine right okay no no you didn't
cheat on your wife if anything he's got
a power Dynamic over me he's young gravy
yeah yeah what about
what about when you're assaulting my
character in The metaverse does that
count or if it's in the metaphors that
is kind of a Cutting Edge HR issue yeah
a bleeding edge HR issue yeah
we'll have to consult with higher powers
on that yeah
typically yeah so they cut his ass out
fans are also expecting that it looks
like Ned was edited out of both the try
guys ruined chocolate eclair videos and
try guys try stand up cut them off so
here he is clearly in the video
man that's kind of wild they're just on
the editing floor just cutting his ass
out of everything
didn't wouldn't that draw more attention
to it I just don't know if that was like
the best thing to do
six days ago the try guys announced they
would be switching to only posting vid
one video per week dude
fans noticed that in the Instagram
photos
both Ned and Alex were in Vegas during
the filming of Keith's eat the menu
episode but they do not appear in the
video hmm
some fans speculate that a section of
the buffet video was left out
oh [ __ ] is this the girl
yes yep okay [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so here they are
he's over here playing it cool right
is this her could you say her name by
the way like everybody like Alexandra I
don't know yeah and like everybody okay
all right spamming it in the chat I was
just trying to be considerate but I I
realized I don't think there's any
consideration for her yeah it seems like
everyone knows it so what what what's
her name it's [ __ ]
Alexandra hearing hurrying hurrying
hearing
more like Alexander Alexandria red
herring or well no not really
nice truck is this her fiancee Fred
Flintstone ass looking [ __ ]
the yabba dabba doo [ __ ]
sure I'll see oh my gosh
how much does he look like Brad
Flintstone that's even the outfit oh my
God
[ __ ] spot on
oh okay
so here they are that redeemed your red
herring joke before okay
thank you thank you sorry to uh her
fiance I know you're going through a
hard time so sorry about that I don't I
don't know I don't think that's him
that's not him I don't think so I'm
looking on her Instagram
what was that
yes
so here they are they are all in Vegas
uh it's another producer people are
saying oh okay so which one of them is
sleeping with him
one of the other yeah Barney's wife is
that Keith so a Reddit user then joins
The Fray
claims they caught Ned doing something
bad when another user asks for proof
they actually send it
I was wondering I was in New York City
because if so I think there's something
you should know unfortunately so wait
who's I was confused by these DMs
who are they talking to because the
person responding seems to be having a
personal
interest in this
I believe that this is uh her fiance
who's receiving this oh
yes she was why basically I went out to
uh
Niagara the club last night and I
started making out with Ned
I have videos if you need it she was
wearing a red dress I don't know if that
helps please send them to me
move yo
Fred Flintstone about that grab that big
old [ __ ] tree Club it's not the
fiance is kind of a [ __ ] Bam Bam
scramble his way over there on the
ground
in his car
so they send the videos
obviously grainy as hell but apparently
it's you could see them kissing clearly
I mean listen if you're a public figure
and the try guys are relatively popular
and you're like the
you're the [ __ ] wife guy
making out in public is absolutely
bananas if you're trying to cheat
right
if you slow it down you can see it she's
in the red
maybe they had already like
I wonder if he had already dropped the
bomb on his family and was like I'm
gonna be with her oh my God the chat is
being
extremely obnoxious by the way because
we don't know everything about the try
guys already so just just just so you're
aware that uh they're pretty upset okay
the tri-stand yeah it's not it's not
Fred Flintstone okay yeah we got it
thank you so much yeah is her um
fiance a public figure
because I can show him if he is but if
he's not I don't want to dig into that
but I like to see his response here the
poor guy's getting his heart torn out
thanks when was the last when was this
last night no worries my apologies I'm
so sorry yes last night what time around
1 to 3 A.M where was this Niagara by NYU
okay thank you dude this person's a real
one
sent him the address and everything
dude you're gonna cheat on your wife at
a 3.6
starred bar should at least make sure
it's like a 4.5 at least
right
damn
at least go out in class [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
and then allegedly a random person
messaged that Reddit user sending them a
blurry video
that they claim is Ned making out with a
woman in the red dress
Hamilton the red user says he talked to
Arielle about it for an hour whoa
this Reddit user is getting in the
[ __ ] mix
he's not a public figure by the way okay
yeah
so he oh my God they're so busted
will Thayer who is Alex from the food
babies fiancee okay so that's removed
all his photos with her and does not
follow her anymore and his account is
now private
that poor man
that's gotta hurt so bad Olivia is
coming in from New York to say they've
been together for 11 years I knew she
would have Intel the you know the one
Olivia we need you you're gone she's the
T Queen
Olivia's giving us tea from across the
country she says
a lot Alex
and her fiance were together for 11
years
and he has now unfollowed her
[ __ ]
their photos together are still up
though
but neither of them put up a statement
yo if somebody told me that they cheated
like they have footage of Ila cheating
on me I would be like
it would be impossible to believe
but here it is here's the video
YB who is close friends with Alex I know
his YB but that's the girl's fiance and
is the other of the food babies isn't a
food baby like a [ __ ]
yes
okay there's a little funny little
comedy moment
is no longer following both Alex and Ned
remember this is all rumor and
speculation at this point the try guys
have not confirmed anything yet
and then
Ned Fulmer is officially
making a statement on Instagram well
this was yeah this is the try guys first
and then Ned made it oh okay so this is
the try guys dropping the bomb
here they go Ned Fulmer is no longer
working with the try guys
as a result of a thorough thorough
internal review so that means they knew
for a while during the soy face era I'm
just going to say that because he slept
with a producer so you got to
investigate that
so they were soy facing through the pain
and that's fine what else you're
supposed to do this business as usual
you got it soy face through the pain I
mean
as a result of the thorough internal
review we do not see a path forward
together we thank you for your support
as we navigate this change
you think they'll get up a pick up a new
try guy or just go down to the three of
them
although they'll become the try guys
yeah the name makes more sense
so maybe this is for the best the try
guys the business is for the best
that's really clever it's not the quad
guys yeah
try guys uh Ned now releases a statement
with soy face icon this man has not
updated this guy is soy [ __ ] face
you gotta love it
ouchy
he says family should have always been
my priority but I lost focus and had a
concept consensual workplace
relationship
I loved how he spins that that's enough
euphemism for destroying your life and
like everybody's life in there and
throwing the whole world upside down
because you couldn't keep it in your
pants
go to the bathroom and jerk off man
what's the big [ __ ] deal if it's
really that serious
I'm already taking my pants off eight
quarterings halfway there
yeah Courtney actually got divorced I
think did we I don't know if I mentioned
that but I don't
know if that had any basis in reality no
he made a comment on Twitter about how
she went out for pizza without him and
never came back he he did make some
comment on Twitter I don't know if it
was I think he was just trolling no dude
his wife never came back yo thanks Ethan
Klein
I mean who would be stay married to him
it doesn't surprise me he's more
surprising that she stayed then well I
would assume there's probably some
evidence of that speaking of pizza I
just sent Ned's Instagram story
this is my favorite thing to come yeah
so let me finish this and I'll show that
so he says I had a consensual workplace
relationship
I guess he's trying to make it clear
like hey guys I didn't like that's his
way of being like it's not like I are
worded anyone
I'm sorry for any pain that my actions
may have caused to the guys and the fans
but most of all to Arielle the only
thing that matters right now is my
marriage and my children
and that's where I'm going to focus my
attention you idiot
you were making out with her at a bar
in public man
big fat kiss
uh then of course this is his story
which hits heart really hard and really
special uh kind of moment this is
literally what his Instagram stories was
so future eyes so here the first one is
homemade pizza night let's go let's go
and then
then and that pizza do look good oh [ __ ]
wait tell me more about the pizza wait
can we just can we hear just a little
bit of music because the music is so
[ __ ] perfect yeah yeah it's so funny
let me hit it like right before it
switches
you got that Zach okay
yeah right here
oh [ __ ] not the amore
[Laughter]
can't write this stuff
you cannot write that
when your heart makes a part like a big
pizza yeah uh I cheated on my wife
my life's ruined I've been fired me I'm
divorced I just bought a book Cookbook
cooking for divorce dad's record
that's a record of scratch moment
totally man you don't get those often
but there it is
that's a big piece of pie
I had a consensual that's so good I had
a consensual
Affair workplace relationship
you also [ __ ] your employee
which is kind of a big deal but damn
that pizza did look good oh my God that
did look they cook that at home that's
really impressive
well it's in the divorced dad cookbook
you know all right wait hold on let me
pull up that people say it's the pizza
curse
what was it Domino's no it was homemade
it's true
yo that's you made this all
so so let me get this straight Med
former collab on the show you should
come in maybe
just don't mention anything
no we're not interested in talking about
the drama we just thought your pizza
looked excellent him and Chef Josh have
a cook-off with Ethan
what I'm getting from this is that
right before this all came out
he was at home with his family
pretending like nothing
making these it's Amore videos
meanwhile harboring harboring this dark
Horrible Secret not just to his wife but
to his workplace this man [ __ ] over
the two spheres of his life you go work
you got home he managed to Nuke them
both yeah brutal that is special I I
gotta admit it to him
damn that one looks good dude
that is amore
anyway uh anyway oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
buzz kill man
good news is the quarter ring is still
married
that is good news thank God
girl you can do better I don't know you
I don't know you look like I don't even
think about you but you can do better
poor
yeah I'm just saying
unless he's right unless you like have a
hobby of [ __ ] down your basement
drain then maybe you guys are a good
match I don't know but I am her biggest
fan
um
moving on
Arielle Ned's wife has now posted a
statement
because at first when I heard about this
I was like maybe they have an
arrangement you know
but based on this I don't think so
thanks everyone has reached out to me it
means a lot nothing is more important to
me than Ned and Ned than our family
and all we requests right now is that
you respect our privacy for the sake of
our kids
are we
are we [ __ ] that up right now
when I think respect our privacy I think
I generally think like trying to reach
out for comment or like
get them to well should we call Olivia
off because she's actually we sent her
to peek in the window and take pictures
Rift through the trash
should we call that off Olivia call it
off Olivia if you're listening
abort abort
uh poor woman
how do you explain that to your kids man
young boys
the try guys have rebranded their social
media page these [ __ ] move fast
as removed the try guys is a dinosaur
what are you talking about what's a
dinosaur have to do with anything
do we like that
well it's a try that's not the it's a
triceratops and I don't think that's the
Rebrand I think it's just like in the
description they took them out and stuff
and
the hearts the the colored hearts uh
represent the three of them there was a
red one for Ned but it's he had the red
one that was a big one when it comes to
Hearts I mean yeah
and I I do it's a big deal I do think
that is a triceratops yeah I think
you're right I get it yeah good good
call there Zach
oh somebody said bro Ethan is a wife guy
you got you better talk some [ __ ] on Elo
right now okay listen I'm not a wife guy
when do I ever like gush about my
marriage and [ __ ] I am happily married
don't get me wrong but
I'm not like do that sometimes I'm not
like rubbing it in people's face am I
listen when I host a panel on the ethics
of
relationship or whatever it's called
then you can call me out okay
well that's going to be the special
segment for the uh HD live show
and do a seminar you should do a lot we
should do a bunch you want to do a song
live there Zach called the Troubadour
and
from probably
yeah I'll do ethics of a relationship
panel at the live show number step one
don't cheat everyone's saying you're
definitely a wife guy you are a wife guy
Ethan definitely a wife guy LMAO
definitely a wife guy not like him
it would be fun to do like a live Ted
talk about something stupid that would
be fun it wouldn't be very long I'm just
saying can we actually pull up the video
of that because I would love to
know what is the recipe
for ethical marriage of their like
seminar yeah I mean
I
don't even know if it was recorded dear
W Dan I reached out to your voice
something about Harry Mack
that's the guy who we don't know who is
well we somewhat know now they keep
donating are you Gary Mack bro
I said I'd look into it you know the
message has been received I will
investigate Harry Mack not not too
familiar with him but they said that uh
he's real cool and would be a great
guest so we'll uh we'll look into it
thanks Omar
AKA Harry
um so yada yada yada and the wife
commented on it
they rebranded
also girl not because Ned from try guys
is wearing the same shirt and the
pictures and Alex from food babies also
has the same purse it ain't looking good
for them wait hold on hold the phone
I passed them on your way to the 200
level of the escalator
I saw Ned and Alex oh my God they took a
picture together
what are you doing
they took like a fan photo
what no that's a fan taking a photo with
Ned they're just using that as proof
okay I thought that was her no no no no
so she she ran into him I got a selfie
Alex seemed annoyed that I recognized
them
and was talking to them it was just the
two of them and didn't see anyone else I
mean they're being pretty flagrant about
it just going on public dates and stuff
as public figures it
it's weird I mean
maybe they've just it's been going on
for a while and thought that they could
uh
continue to get away with it or they're
just really dumb yeah it's hard to say I
don't know
so I can't find the video but I found
the link to the website of the
University that has the event down there
that gives a little description
wait what is the what is the uh the bomb
here so here he is and then here's Alex
what's
she says
wearing the same shirt in the picture
and Alex from food babies what shirt
okay whatever oh
I mean I don't the speculation is uh
over the stage the same shirt and the
same purse as in the photos of them
cheating yes it's just proof that it's
memory it's just further proof that
there's that right but I mean it again
they already admitted to it so it's
kind of a moot point at this point yeah
yeah
so there it is uh just rich with irony
it's a tragic tale a sad Tale
filled with soy
and sadness and and you know and it's a
sexual dance and it's a sexual dance
maybe they'll maybe they'll
maybe they'll make it work would it be
better if they started like if they got
married and had like a lifelong
commitment to each other him and the
producer
uh generally relationships born out of
infidelity don't work out too well uh
but maybe they'll be the how the [ __ ]
you gonna trust your partner when they
cheated yeah exactly you're not really
building on a very uh strong Foundation
at that point there was a um
upper two School administrators at my
school
both were married and they were cheating
with each other and I think they've been
together going on 10 years now
they left their Partners to be with each
other
due to high capacity registration is
closed
this this was a total hit
February 2020
live streaming will be available though
comedian Ned Fulmer and his wife Arielle
have produced videos together for
YouTube over the past six years
on topics finding a house remodeling
having a baby and also having a discrete
relationship with your employee that was
a video they made the try guys explore
offbeat scenarios and situations
the group blah blah blah
so yeah just a basic description
I wish I had more yeah
I'd love to see this man I'm dying to
see this
how could this not be how could this not
be on the internet
well whatever
and I guess that's let's see
um
try guys put a statement Ned Pizza 15.
yeah there's also this one
there was this one that went viral and
tick tock
they're just like in a lot of other
businesses right now oh sure it's barely
being a salad it's misbehaving salad
that like cheats on its wife you know
they're just like in a lot of other
businesses right now oh sure the guilty
reaction right he seems so guilty bro
he can't even pretend that like that's
not all about him
so
was he just skirting around it or was it
just a coincidence do you think you want
to know what I think the other try guys
I think they knew
with one of their producers of course
they would know
right
I don't know I mean the opposite I think
he's able to hide it because of that
reason
because they do work together right they
would have like a good excuse to be yeah
working closely together cruising around
New York
just kissing in the open like that
there's no way there's something more to
this story in my opinion also that the
you're right even followed up on the
random DM like she knows something is
going on already or something happened
before
there's you're asking people say they
definitely knew they knew yeah sad face
yeah he knew they knew everyone knew I
think the W Keith comments coming from
if he knew well we don't know for sure
what I'm just saying it overwhelming
response in the chat that oh yeah they
definitely knew and it's like well then
that kind of low-key [ __ ] up right are
they all like friends with with the wife
oh God somebody just said
uh [ __ ] where's my mouse some speculate
that it might be staged for a future
video there is no way oh that would be
really insane thing to do if they did
that they would never be forgiven but no
dude fousey and ricegum already tried
the whole uh oh we were doing it just to
show how we could trick the internet
that's an old it's old now wait hold on
I was only pretending yeah what's what
is he doing here
he's trying to see that Bedrock you guys
like that one so much we just kept them
coming
that was a good joke I mean so this
remember the uh
the text message with like the hint just
like came from some random person
messaging the fiance or but that was
after the big threat on Reddit I think
so she was already aware of that I'm
sure right I'm just saying what if that
was one of the other try guys from like
an anonymous number
that was their way dropping the bomb
just saying
yeah it's all speculation obviously but
my question is how long was this going
on for that would be
so you know a lot of people in the chat
saying it was probably going on for like
since I saw people saying December 2021
so like a year
all new
I think the wife's new too I think this
is respected Maybe
yeah maybe right so people have been
speculating on Reddit for months I see
this is uh something Olivia sent
um anyone have any more Ned Fuller and
Alex T how long has this been going on I
need Deets oh this is the [ __ ] gossip
Instagram page you were telling me about
Olivia do more right
where they spill the tea on celebs so
here we go December 2021 Alex's fiancee
well went through her phone
and saw her and Ned had hooked up while
on some work trip
they ended up staying together
but will reach out to Ned warning him to
back off
beginning of this month I want to say
September 1st or 2nd will and Ned's wife
Game of Thrones trying to
I need like a key with all the names
uh will and Ned's wife Arielle received
videos and pictures from a few people
showing Ned and Alex making out at a
club as well as holding hands during the
day at a market
Ariel had just landed in New York City
to meet up with the try guys and their
significant others but got the news
confronted Ned and when
confronted Ned and when he confirmed him
and Alex had been in a relationship for
almost a year she got back on a plane
and came back to LA immediately not sure
how the NYC event played out
but Ned
and Alex were suspended almost
immediately
okay
when try guys had talks with employees
Manny said they had noticed flirting
knew that they had lunch hookups stayed
at each other's places occasionally and
showed up to events together
apparently they showed up together to a
Harry Styles concert and had big feels
something was up so this news had been
aware to the try guys for close to a
month but what sparked the social media
questioning was then uproar of the few
images of the DMS he received on Reddit
obviously Ned has been fired
I believe all that this is dumoy they
never miss
is that true they don't these people
they know everything it's crazy wow
right Olivia I mean these guys don't
ever Miss
was it Whitney that told you about them
or Olivia it came up on the Whitney
episode and Olivia immediately was like
yeah okay
a huge announcement by the president
I'll be an appointing the next try guy
member by the end of the month
so that's that'll be something we can
all look forward to there oh God I miss
it it's one of the highest uh highest
responsibilities of the US president
it's the appointment of it's a lifetime
appointments no lifetime appointment to
the try a guy yeah you want to get that
right barring accusations of infidelity
man
um
this is such juice
you could be a try guy I got my own
thing going on I'm not trying I don't
know I got like a whole empire over
there
I'm not trying to be a try guy man hey
try H try it with all the producers
trying to ruin my marriage
oh yeah the DU Moy guys are the people
that knew Whitney ate cheese only off
the pizza right yeah and left the bread
yeah
they saw Whitney Cummings at an airport
bar eating cheese off of the pizza
that's a good Scoop man
people saying they definitely miss a lot
yeah that was my assumption I mean
not saying that this this one is untrue
oh they do miss
I mean it's a It's like a Rumor Mill
page of course some of the rumors are
going to be [ __ ] all right well now
the payoff this comes to the fun part of
putting again all the putting aside all
the pain and suffering here were all the
great memes that came out of this
crying oh my God who edited the try Guy
Wiki page for Ned
you scroll down more the hidden the try
guide the hidden power of [ __ ] up
the try guy came out with their book on
April called the try guy the hidden
power [ __ ] up the TR the uh here
I thought that was the real book I was
gonna say that that part's all real the
joke is the circle part uh as of
September 22 Ned decides to be a [ __ ]
and try adultery
doesn't seem that it worked out but
uh I guess that remains to be seen I'm
really invested in the drama surrounding
a guy who looks like this that's not him
wait that's not it's not him not him
that's not him
but that is the soy face I refer to and
um again
guys even if you love Keith you gotta
admit
there's something about that face
just saying
oh boy
my face man
try guys try infidelity dude that's the
best soy piece what the [ __ ]
these guys practically invented soy face
posting this kind of statement with the
Avi honestly rocks yeah I saw that so
good
please
like comment and subscribe epic marriage
gone wrong not clickbait
oh that's it I thought there was more
check Discord real quick
okay you're in bro I see you guys are
really pushing
bro so you gotta back off with these
comments
Shrine guy
[Laughter]
maybe I was in trouble well maybe Justin
Bieber should be the fourth Dragon oh
interesting
I'm trying to think but nothing happens
guys it's not gonna happen I'm just I'm
not a good fit for them
okay you fit right in what are you
talking about the last wife guy didn't
work
they don't need another wife guy
foreign
true what they need is a single stud
afraid of commitment guys what they
needed at this point yep trying to
well there it is guys
um a whole thing there with the the try
guys ladies and gentlemen
you know
there it is
it's incredible how dumb people can be
you know like this guy spent his whole
life he achieved every dream he could
ever imagine success a huge
[ __ ] successful media Empire with his
best buddies
beautiful wife two beautiful kids
and like
you just gave it up man
and she had a fiance too like you this
was never gonna work out
it's that post-coital regret my friend
dude oh my God
you know after he nutted he must have
felt like the biggest idiot every time
do women women don't have voice quote or
regret do they
or is that a uniquely male thing
sure
can we do a poll I mean I'm just curious
because when I think post Boyle regret I
think it's regrets about a little
different I think
but yeah we do pull for you guys that
don't know what that is there's like
it's just a kind of like a silly meme
but apparently
after you not
then all the horniness drains out of
your brain
and then you like get to see things
logically again and realize that you
absolutely [ __ ] up well I see lots of
yeses so there it's like nothing but
yeses yeah I guess I don't think we need
the post-quital regret is a universal
experience I'm Gonna Come
that's just that sucked that's the worst
feeling man
well I ain't never had no post way to
regret like what this guy did
[ __ ]
try guys try post quarter regret
post not Clarity some people call it
yeah I stand corrected
you know I wasn't sure either not to not
to uh I just didn't know you know yeah I
mean like I I kind of knew they did but
it's not like
without being too dirty they could never
mind go ahead they can keep going where
a guy is like once he's busting out he's
done
that was the main distinction so you're
saying
so you're saying that you're such an
incredible lover no that you are giving
so many orgasms to your significant
others is never ending
there's never even a chance to feel
regret in this orgasm Frenzy
again after everything I say
I'm just kidding I know what you mean I
mean I don't exactly yeah I know what
you're doing you beat yeah you'd be
buzzing nuts
so true AB some people say we keep going
thank you yeah I mean once once a guy
finishes the night's over exactly
Boomer podcast energy
[Music]
there it is a b the star lover
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
sorry Lena I know it's awkward for you
to talk about that you're sitting right
there I don't feel awkward at all okay
good yeah
yeah
Lena really is uh the best what what are
you
doing
she is the best she really is the best
well thank you guys yeah
um you guys want so there's other story
that I find really interesting which is
the chess cheating scandal
but we can also talk about NyQuil
chicken
uh we've been going for three hours and
I unfortunately am going to push for
wrapping it up because we have a big
show tomorrow morning that we have to
prepare for and also Ela seemed like she
was kind of caught up on the chest uh
situation so maybe she well we could
talk about him Friday yeah yeah she's
pretty into that story I've been really
so let me see if there's something we
can quickly look at here
let's see
um
uh
National oh this was so sick
NASA crashed a [ __ ] spacecraft into a
asteroid
this happened
um gosh two days ago
called the dart project which is the
first ever
test
I'm gonna go rip a dart of of earthlings
to
uh collide with a celestial object to
change its course
the idea the theory is that if there's a
meteorite or asteroid coming that's
going to smash into the Earth you can
send these little ships
and the theory is if you crash into them
you can change the orbit just enough so
that it will miss Earth
this is good [ __ ] yo we should all be
happy about this darts business a rep of
Dart you know what I mean
come on what's his Russia and Ukraine
are fighting
we got to be having darts in space
that's what's that's what's important
uh shout out to Ukraine though by the
way
shout out this is a collided with the
asteroid which was the size of a
football stadium wow that's big
pretty cool that is awesome yeah I've
always kind of been afraid of that
if I start thinking too much about [ __ ]
that could happen
well actually I've heard
um from an uh Astro astronomer that at
the moment we've tracked every big
asteroid that could potentially have
like life-ending consequences and we're
good for now thank god oh but our
grandkids might be [ __ ] no I think
they can they can track them with like
the with like hundreds of years oh okay
yeah I don't care about that but there's
a chance uh that there's stuff we
haven't seen but
it's good to be prepared am I right yeah
just saying love that to NASA Dart
Dan is fuming over there
no I'm not okay I thought you were angry
because I went a little bit longer
yeah just a little bit longer you know
uh let's do one more
let's see
uh we did Big Brother
we did you go the NyQuil chicken is
pretty good
okay let's just call it you're right
down
these are all log segments
well if you guys want more you can
become a member and watch our show
Tuesday exclusive see you next Tuesday
but we're gonna listen to the show
what listen to the show there's nothing
and yeah there's no video
people are saying free Dan
um anything anyone else wants to say
before we wrap it up here
no I mean uh just I we should say again
uh thanks to everybody who bought the
tickets to the live show yeah it's
exciting so good sold out so quick that
was so nice you guys thank you we're all
really really excited to see you guys
all out there and have a show it's going
to be fun and uh yeah so tomorrow
morning Big Show Hassan is coming out
and the one and only Liverpool will be
here yeah
yeah I'll be eating some raw liver I'm
sure
and a lot more than that probably some
goat testicles I don't know if I can do
all that you gotta do it he's bringing a
chef why do you need a chef to eat a raw
testicle he's those I don't know
sommelier that's a good point testicle
sommelier yeah penis liver that's a
really good point why is he bringing a
chef he eats everything wrong what do
they do what the [ __ ] does he do cut it
I mean okay preparation do they put salt
on it I'm so mad I'm gonna be missing it
look at my wisdom teeth removed tomorrow
oh no yeah
it's been like this is like the third
time I've rescheduled and like they keep
pushing it back like months so
yeah you're having them all taken out
tomorrow yeah and I'm they're putting me
under oh that's good I was gonna say
make sure to do that because you do not
want to be awake for that [ __ ] yeah is
it more expensive but it's so worth it
yeah wouldn't it be good content if you
came in while you were on the thing I'll
record it or maybe we'll get something
you know record him when he wakes up and
see if he says some wild [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to get some good content out of it
since he's making me miss liver King
yes I do I've been hearing all about it
yeah I'm so sorry
I'll make it up to you well we could get
some good content so everything's
content guys
yep
um
well we wish you luck
thank you you know why are you getting
the procedures your wisdom teeth [ __ ]
your mouth up yeah they're coming in and
I still I had a crown put in where I
lost that tooth and before they could
put in the permanent Crown I need to
remove the wisdom teeth because it's
pushing up on the back teeth so do you
have pain from where they are or not
really not a lot a little bit yeah
that's interesting yeah
people who believe in intelligent design
you can basically just say wisdom teeth
if God created humans to be you know In
His Image imperfect or whatever we would
not have our mouths be too small for
wisdom teeth
dub easy where's your God now
wow
we don't know about they're there to
challenge you bro God put wisdom teeth
there because he loves Dentistry do you
think liver King has his wisdom teeth
I feel like it's subprime I'll get them
taken out yeah kind of that's subtle
Behavior question we can ask him
tomorrow yeah let's find out um unless
you take them out yourself like oh
that's right that's one of the most
ultimate Primal acts yeah yeah yeah
that might be super primal this is above
yeah yeah
God took the L today though for sure
don't mess up
but not good you're good are you
superstitious if we talked in on God
that your procedure might go wrong
sure we'll go with that okay so after
the procedure we can yeah
we'll let her rip
Checkmate atheists
um all right
that's a bit guys hey thanks for
watching had a fun app you know
good time
lots of love to the try guy's wife
and fiancee
if you're looking for a new try guy I
guess I'll throw my hat in there why not
give us a soy face then the show
I don't I don't do it like them
too much teeth I think that's that's key
oh wait wait
thank you Chris Turner beats for the 50
gifted then we get actually the gifted
now is so cool because they get to watch
the free podcast now so that's really
dope it's really good thank you for the
game Tim is that our Saudi Prince yup
Chris Turner beats Harry Mack
oh no poor Harry Matt Jesus
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning thanks everyone for watching
love you Tata no eating NyQuil chicken
guys those
do not mix those
[Music]
[Music]